ما أحد يحط 20 مليون على مطعم
فكان يقولوا أَنتُم مهابيل
أَنتُم بالحجم وبالكبر هذا
أشياء كثير لما تيجي تقرأ في النظام هي غير موجودة
لكن هي عُرف أصبَحت بمثابة نِظام
على سبيل المثال: باب أفراد وباب عوائل
هو عرُف وليس النِّظام!
كان أول ما فتح يجينا 4 آلاف اتصال في اليوم طلب حجز في «بليونير»
يا ساتر!
ناس يقارنون بين مقهى «إِيرث» الرِّياض
ومقهى «إِِيرث» دبي، وكلها أَنتُم تملكونها
واحنا نملكها
تبيعون في دبي أرخص
صحيح
وفي السعوديَّة أغلى
قاعدين تستغلون السعوديين، وللا أيش الفكرة؟
هذا سُقراط مِن شركة ثَمانية
وأنا عُمر الجريسي أستضيف قادة التَّحول وقادة الأعمال وقادة الرأي
ضيف حلقتنا اليوم هو الأستاذ فيصل شاكر
شريك ورئيس تنفيذي لشركة المأكولات العصريَّة
المسؤولة عن تأسيس وإدارة مجموعة من المطاعم الرَّاقية
أو ما يسمى الـ (Fine dining)
حلقة مهمة في توقيتها بسبب موجة الخسائر
والإقفالات اللي تصير في كثير من هذه المطاعم
كيف لهذه الشَّركة اللي أول مشاريعها كان يربح من ثاني سنة
وغطى رأس ماله في أقل من سنتين
أن اليوم مبيعاتها فوق 600 مليون، وتخسر؟
أيش اللي تغير في القطاع؟
سولفنا عن المواسم السّياحية
وعلاقتها بنَّجاح أو تراجع أداء هذه المطاعم
تكلَّمنا عن المنافسة بين القطاع الخاص
والمطاعم المدعومة من جهات حكومية
تكلمنا عن فرق التَّكلفة بين المطاعم اللي تُشغَّل في السعوديَّة
واللي تُشغَّل في دول الخليج
تكلمنا عن فرق الأسعار
ليش الأسعار عندنا أكثر وأعلى عادةً من دول الخليج
رغم أنه نفس المطعم والمُشغل والمالك للعلامة
تكلمنا أيضًا على أسرار النَّجاح
هُم عندهم واحدة من أنجح العلامات التِّجارية السعوديَّة
في قطاع المطاعم الرَّاقية، فأيش أسرار النَّجاح؟
أيش الأهم، هل هو الأكل وللا الخدمة، وللا الجو العام؟
كل هذه الملفات هي جزء أساسي من برنامج جودة الحياة
ومستهدفات محددة في عدد المطاعم الرَّاقية
أو المطاعم اللي تخدم هذه الشريحة السياحية المهمة
وختمنا بمجموعة من أسئلتكم الثمينة
سواءً أسئلة الموظفين اللي يسألون عن
ليش رواتب السعوديين في هذه الشَّركة أقل من نظرائهم غير السعوديين؟
ليش أحد المطاعم جودة الخدمة فيه أقل من جودة مطعم آخر
مع أنهم لنفس الشَّركة ونفس الإدارة
وتكلمنا أيضًا على موضوع سياسة التَّسعير
وعن نصائحه للي في القطاع اليوم
للشخص اللي ناوي يدخل في قطاع المطاعم
والشخص اللي خلال عملية تطوير المطعم
والشخص اللي مسبقًا متورط في مطعم، وقاعد يخسر
أيش نصائح ضيفنا لكل شخص من هؤلاء
إلى آخر أسئلكم الثمينة
هذه الحلقة برعاية شركة «صفا»
أترككم مع الحوار
حيَّاك الله أبو عبد اللَّه شرفتنا و نورتنا
الله يسلمك، يا أبو عبد الرحمن
وشكرًا لاستضافتي اللَّه يسلمك
الأخوين مصرفيين، أيش دخلكم في قطاع المطاعم «أنتَ وأُسامة»؟
حلوة هذه، نقطة مهمة، توهقنا
بداية قويَّة
توهقنا
لا هذا شغف طال عمرك
شلون بدأ؟
طال عمرك، الفكرة بدأتها أنا و«أُسامة، أبو محمد»
وشريكنا «أبو سلطان» في ذاك الوقت
من عام 2009
«أبو سلطان» اللي هو؟
«محمد جاوة»
كانت بدأت في عام 2009 كفكرة، وكُنَّا نسافر
كان عندنا هواية بسيطة جدًّا ، وليس محترفين، هُواة
أن عندنا فريق سباق سيارات
وكنا نشارك في سباقات في المنطقة سواءً أيَّامها كانت حلبة «الريم»
على سبيل المثال في الرّياض والبحرين والـ«بي أي سي» وغيرها
ودبي وأبوظبي، و«لاسيل» في الدوحة في قطر
فأثناء كان سفرنا، تعرف السباقات تصير في عطلة نهاية الأسبوع
في يوم للتدريب، ويوم للتأهيل، وبعدين يوم للسِباق، ثلاثة أيام عادةً
يوم تدريب، يوم تأهيل، يوم السِّباق
يوم السِّباق، التأهيل والسِّباق
فلمَّا كنا نسافر صح أنَّ أغلب المحترفين يناموا بدري، ويصحوا بدري
عشان التأهيل للسباق لكن احنا خلاص راح علينا الاحتراف، رحنا هواة
فنطلع ونتعشى ونروح ونجي، ونروح نحجز مطاعم
وين حجزت مطعم، وين راح نحجز مطعم نروح؟
فكان عندنا شغف واهتمام انتبهنا
أن وين نحجز مطعم؟ ونروح المطعم
وأثناء احنا راحين أصلًا إلى مهمة أخرى
اللي هي الاستمتاع بالسِّباق
فتضرب عصفورين بحجر
أنت تستمتع شيء أنت تحبه تطلع وتتمشي وتروح مطاعم
وفي نفس الوقت كمان تستمتع بهوايتك الحلوة
فمن هناك الفكرة بدأت تَتَبلور
ليش ما عندنا احنا في الرّياض؟
احنا من سكان الرِّياض، ليش ما عندنا في الرِّياض في السعوديَّة مطاعم
بنفس طبيعة المطاعم اللي نشوفها خارج السعوديَة اللي نحب نروح لها؟
من هنا قلنا: هل تتوقعوا أن يكون عليها طلب؟
قلنا يا جماعة، لمَّا نسافر نصف المطاعم سعوديين
أكيد أن في عليها طلب، نصف الموجودين في المطاعم سعوديين
وما أخفيك،
هل تتوقع أن هذا المطاعم تشتغل من غير الكحول؟
طيب ما يشربون، جالسين في المطعم، وما أحد يشرب
احنا نروح، وما احنا قاعدين نشرب
جالسين نستمتع في المطعم
أكيد نفس الشيء كل أحد راح ييجي وما راح يشرب، ويستمتع بالمطعم
فليش نربط المطعم بوجوبيَّة وجود الكحول في المطعم؟
فقلنا خلونا نفكر في أفكار، فكرنا في أفكار كثيرة مضحكة يعني تضحك
نرسل النموذج لعدَّة شركات برة
على سبيل المثال «سنيور ساسي» الآن الموجود عندنا
يرد علينا أن، أيش الملف التعريفي حقكم؟
في ذاك الوقت ما عندنا ملف تعريفي
كشركة قائمة وعندها خبرة في التشغيل
هو فيه شغف وشركة تحب المجال هذا وتفهم، وعندها يمكن تذوُّق
وهذا الشيء...
فأغلبهم يردوا ويقولوا ما نقدر هذه مُجازفة أن نعطيك حق الامتياز
وأنت ما عندك خبرة تشغيل، هذا ما هو بسيط
فكلمنا مجموعة مطاعم
فصرنا نشوف حتى من مطعم مصري إلى مطعم...
أنتوا كلمتوا «سنيور ساسي» تقول، وكلَّمتوا «زوما» بعد
أرسلنا «زوما» وأرسلنا...
«أبو السَّعيد« وللا أيش اسم المطعم؟
«أبو السّيد»
يعني «زوما» و«أبو السيد»
مختلفين بس ندور، نبغى المطعم
الفكرة عندنا شغف أن نروح مكان نطلع
نروح في الليل، النَّاس تعزم أحد، وتروح تغير جو
ولا كان الفكر تجاري بحت
ولا كان الفكر مبني أن المطعم فيه أرباح عالية أو قليلة
لا، كان جاي من شغف
وكان الشَّغف هذا، بعدين تولد لغيرة
أن لا، لازم يكون عندنا نفس الشيء، ليش ما عندنا؟
فهي هذه كان فيها غيرة
أن ليش احنا ما عندنا؟ نفس الشيء
لأن إذا كُنت تفكر كمستثمر فقط
ممكن تروح تفتح مطعم خارج في مكان مضمون
الخطر فيه أقل في ذاك الوقت
لا، في غيرة أن ليش لازم أسافر في الإجازات عشان أستمتع بالمطعم؟
وأول ما أسوي أحجز مطعم
أبغَى أستمتع هنا في إجازتي في الرِّياض
فجلستوا تحاولون مع كل هذه العلامات
ولأن ما عندكم تاريخ في إدارة المطاعم
فالأسماء المرتبة كانوا يرفضونكم
كانوا يرفضوننا في ذاك الوقت بأدب واحترام
ويبقى الاحترام
شلون طِحتوا على...
تحولت طال عمرك إلى مطعم «نزومي» في لندن
هو مطعم مُستقل في ذاك الوقت في بيتشامبليس
مطعم «نزومي» مطعم مُعاصر ياباني
وعنده موسيقى وأجواء لطيفة، وعنده أكل، مطعم لا بأس فيه
ما أقدر أقول لك، أكيد ما هو «زوما» ما هو بنفس «زوما»
فالمطعم وافق أنه يعطي حق الامتياز في ذاك الوقت
فكانت بالنسبة لنا فرصة، ولا نقدر نتشرط كثير
وسألنا حولينا كثير أن كيف هذا...؟
قالوا نعرفه، السعوديين اللي نسألهم
السياح ما يعرفوه السعوديين
لكن أغلب السعوديين اللي يعرفوه اللي ساكنين في لندن
إما طلبة أو يشتغل أو يجلسوا إلى فترات طويلة
أو عندهم بيوت، ويقضوا فترات طويلة في لندن
يعرفوا «نزومي» بيتشنبليس
هذا الكلام عام 2011-2012؟
هذا في 2011 تقريبًا
في 2011
في 2011-2010 الكلام هذا
ووافقوا الجماعة، وقلنا حسنًا حق امتياز
جلسنا مع بعض اتفقنا، وقلنا: فكرة نسوِّي «نزومي» الرِّياض
نبدأ بـ«نزومي» الرِّياض
نوقع بـ«نزومي» على مستوى السعوديّة
فاتفاقياتكم أن أنتم تمثلون «نزومي» في كل السعوديَّة
احنا حق امتياز
أيش أهم شروط هذه الوكالة؟
أبدًا، الشروط أنك تفتح أول شيء طبعًا مطعم في الرِّياض
يعطوك الشُّروط أن خلال مثلًا اثنى شهر أو ثمانية عشر شهر
ما تحضرني بالتحديد بس عادةً الاتفاقيات يحدد لك
أن أول مطعم من توقيع الاتفاقية
ما يتعدى مثلًا ثمانية عشر شهر أو أربعة وعشرين شهر
حسب أنت في المفاوضات أيش توصل معاهم
احنا ما كان عندنا قوة المفاوضة في ذاك الوقت
تبغى أي أحد يوافق عليك أصلًا
إي يوافق علي، وتنقص الخبرة
الخبرة تجي مع الوقت والخبرة تجي مع التجارب
فكانت أول اتفاقية حق امتياز
فأول شرط أن في مُدة زمنية لازم تفتح فيها الفرع الأول
بالضبط
هل في عدد فروع ألزمك فيها؟
لا، ما ألزمني بعدد فروع
هل ألزمك بنسبة من إجمالي الدخل؟
كان يأخذ نسبة طبعًا اللي هي رسُوم المُلِكية
رسُوم المُلكيَّة كان يأخذ خمسة، وبعدين ترتفع إلى خمسة ونص
وبعدين ترتفع إلى 6% على حسب تطور السنين
من إيراداتك؟
من إجمالي الإيرادات
ربحان أو خسران مو مشكلته
هو راح يأخذ 5% من مبيعاتك
بالضبط
ويأخذ... أنت قلتها...
صافي الأرباح؟
لا، هذه بعض اتفاقيات حقوق الامتياز الثَّانية...
وأخذ مبلغ مقدم؟
مقدم يأخذ مبلغ اللي يسموه الدُّفعة الأوليَّة
وهذا مرة وحدة
هذه مرة وحدة يأخذها
وكم عادةً هذا؟
وبعدين يأخذ على كل فرع زيادة يأخذ دُفعة أوليَّة
فتحت مثلًا في جدة يأخذ عليك 100 ألف أو 50 ألف دولار
والفرع الأول كم أخذ عليكم؟
في ذاك الوقت يمكن كانت 600 ألف دولار
600 ألف دولار
600 ألف دولار في...
ممتاز، هذا هو الهَيكل
هذا الهَيكل
أنتم الثلاثة «فيصل شاكر» و«أسامة شاكر» و«محمد جاوة»
«محمد جاوة»
كان معنا شريك رابع الأخ «نبيل خوجة، أبو حسام» وطلع من بدري
قبلَما تبدأون؟
لا، بعدما بدأنا أول مطعم، بعدما فتحنا أول مطعم
قرر أنه قال: أنا مسافر، التَّوسع مو هوايتي
فكنَّا احنا في خطَّة التَّوسع
فقال: لا، إذا هي مطعم واحد حسنًا، إذا بتتوسعون أنا أعطوني خروج
شلون اخترتوا هذاك المكان اللي بالنسبة للكثيرين
ما هو مكان مميز للمطاعم؟
سبحان اللَّه، هذا المكان...
اللي ما يعرفونه، احنا نتكلم على شارع الضَّباب
شارع الضَّباب
أنتُم أول ناس جِيتوه
أول مطعم يمكن يفتح في شارع الضَّباب
وفعلًا هو أول مطعم يفتح في الشارع
كان الشارع الحيوي هو شارع التحلية الأمير «محمد بن عبد العزيز»
بس أغلبه ما كان فيه مطاعم، أغلبه مقاهي
وخفنا، وفيه زحمة
وزحمته ليست الزحمة اللي هي مرتدي المطاعم الفاخرة
هي مرتدي المقاهي، فبالتالي لازم تنتبه
فبالتالي في بعض النَّاس تتحاشى أنها تمر في شارع التَّحلية
عشان ما تدخل في الزحمة
لما قلنا: الضَّباب، أيش إمكانيَّة الوصول؟
طريق مكة يجون من طريق الملك خالد وطريق الملك عبد العزيز
ففيه إمكانيَّة وصول
طريق شارع الثلاثين الأمير سلطان يوصلك
فاللي راح يوصل هل يوقف لازم في زحمة التًّحلية؟
لا، في عدة طرق للوصول
طبعًا في ذاك الوقت الإيجارات في شارع الضَّباب أرخص
فكانت فرصة أنت تفكر في الإيجار، وفيه مخاطرة عالية، وإلى آخره
فلقينا الموقع، مو أن معناته أن هذا الموقع الوحيد، رحنا أكثر من مكان
واحدة من الأماكن اللي اقتربنا منها، على سبيل المثال، سِنتريَا
قبل شارع الضَّباب
لكن إدارة سِنتريَا ما كان عندها التَّوجه
لأنهم عندهم مطاعمهم الخاصة بهم
في نفس الوقت، ومحلاتهم الخاصة بهم
فما حَبوا أن يستأجروا وإلى آخره
يعني كان وارد أنك تأخذ جوَّا مجمع تجاري؟
إي كان وارد أني أخذ جوا المول زّي مطاعم الآن موجودة كثير في...
«إسهيل»
إي «إسهيل»
بالضبط وفيه مجموعة من المطاعم فيجوا سِنتريا
فواحد من الخيارات كان سِنتريا ، بس اللَّه ما أراد
وثاني شيء هي قسمه ونصيب في المكان، سبحان اللَّه
أخذنا في الضَّباب وتوفقنا
مكان فيه...، جاي أصلًا موجود فيه مواقف
المبنى اللي احنا مستأجرين فيه
احنا مستأجرين، ما نملك
المبنى موجود فيه مواقف متاحة، وما هو مزدحم
خلف المبنى فيه مواقف متاحة
احنا ما لنا علاقة فيها هي مواقف عامَّة
أو مواقف تابعة للمبنى، مواقف أنها موجودة
فهذه كلها مرافق، استفدنا منها بحيث أن تسهل على الزائر للمطعم
أو الضَّيف أنه يوقف سيارته
ويدخل بسهولة يتغدى أو يتعشى ويطلع
من غير ما يتعب أو يتعنى
الحمد للَّه، توفقت، وفتحنا طال عمرك، وأسَّسنا شركة
نرجع إلى سؤالك الأول، أسسنا الشَّركة طال عمرك
لمَّا اتفقنا وكل شيء
تم تأسيس الشَّركة في عام 2012
تأسيس الشَّركة، وبعدين وقعنا الاتفاقية
مع «نزومي» وفتحنا أول مطعم
اللي كان هو «نزومي» الرِّياض في سبتمبر 2014
بس قصة التَّصميم هذه لازم تُقال
أي، قصة التَّصميم هذه قصة
أول شيء لحقنا التَّصميم حق «نزومي» لندن
«نزومي» لندن إذا كان رحته، مو كثيرين اللي راحوه
كان على أوف وايت على رمادي فاتح الفرش ، وإلى آخره
سوينا التَّصميم المبدئي وسوينا الإظهار المعماري
وكان في أول يوم عرض تقديمي جالسين نتفرج
بعدين قلنا: الصَّراحة يعني هل هذا هو أول مطعم نبي نفتحه في الرِّياض
نفتحه بالطريقة والمنظر هذا؟
لا، ما احنا مقتنعين، دفعنا فلوس، وكل شيء
وكملنا مع المكتب الهندسي
قلنا يا جماعة نبغى نسوي شيء أعلى، وأكبر، شيء واو
احنا نبغى نصنع الطَّلب
أنت ما تنتظر الطلب
لا، أنت تفتعل الطلب، وتبغى تسوي شيء عليه القيمة
ناس كثير جاؤوا، قالوا مجانين أنتم، هبل تأخذوا؟
تِبُو تستثمروا 20 مليون في مطعم؟
وأنتم ما تضمنوا مدى جدواه الاقتصادية وإقبال النَّاس؟
النَّاس بتتقبل أو ما بتتقبل؟
المهم قلنا لا، إن شاء اللَّه، راح تتقبل
طالما أن احنا نشوفهم في المطاعم برَّة
شيء من الطَّبيعي والعقل والمنطق
يقول إنهم راح يجوا مطاعم عندك
ما يتعنَّا يروح برَّة، هذا الطَّبيعي
صحيح
سوينا
كلَّمنا قلنا طب خلِّينا ندور على مصمم ثاني، دوَّرنا
أيش المطعم اللي يعجبنا فعلًا
احنا ايش الإلهام حقَّنا كان كمطعم ياباني؟ «زوما» كإلهام
والله قلنا طيب خلِّينا ندور، دورنا مين اللي سوى «زوما»؟
«مكتب ستيديو غلوت»
صاحب المكتب اسمه «نوري سان ياباني»
توصَّلنا إلى استيديو «غلوت» من خلال الإنترنت والبحث
اتصلنا بـ«نوري»
السعوديَّة، حسنًا أهلًا وسهلًا
قِد اشتغلت في السعوديَّة؟
قال: أنا ما قِد سويت أي مشروع في السعوديَّة، لكن تفضلوا
احنا نبغَى نسوِّي مطعم
أيش المطعم؟
مطعم «نزومي» في لندن
نبغى نصمم معاك، أرسلنا له الملف التعريفي لـ«نزومي» لندن
كل الأشياء هذه في إنستقرام
حسنًا عِرف «نزومي» لندن
نِبغى نسوِّيه، ونِبغَاك تصمم لنا إيَّاه
قلنا له: لكن نبغاك تأخذ في الاعتبار أشياء بسيطة
بس أنت كمصمم نعطيك المتطلَّبات
مساحة المطعم 1100 متر مربع تقريبًا
عندنا قسم أفراد وقسم عائِلات
طبعًا في مترجمة، هو ما يتكلم إنقليزي، ياباني بحت
وكانت في مترجمة يابانية معاه اللي المساعدة
هي اللي كانت تترجم
فحتى ترجمتها، هي ما هي فاهمتنا كويس
ولما تترجم له فما نعرف أيش قاعدة تترجم له بالضبط
نقول عوائل، عندنا يعني المطعم
قال لي: كيف أفراد وعوائل؟
قلنا له: يعني لو جاؤوا مجموعة أفراد مع بعض
قسم أفراد وقسم عوائل
وما المفروض أن يشوفوا أو يكشف على قسم العوائل
بس لو سيدات لوحدهم يدخلوا في قسم العوائل
فهو إما ثنائي أو مجموعة سيدات ورجال مع بعض عائلة
أو سيدات لوحدهم، هذا قسمهم
أفراد لوحدهم هذا قسمهم
الرِّجال فعلًا ما استوعب هذا
طبعًا زي ما أقول لك في عامل الترجمة
اللي في النص هذه كمان احنا ما نضمن مدى الترجمة كويسة
لأن يمكن هي ما استوعبت
قلنا له حسنًا، بعدين قلنا له عندنا شيء ثاني
احنا ما عندنا تقديم كحول
ممنوع عندنا في السعوديَّة
سكت، قال أنتم ليش تبُون تسوون مطعم؟
هذا المصمم، قال: أَنتُم أفراد، ومنطقة مهدورة وبعدين عائلة
أنا مَني فاهم
بعدين تقول لي مافي مشروب
كيف مطعم زَي «نزومي» ولا «زوما»
هو يربط «زوما» وما في مشروبات يعني ما تِجي
قلنا: لا، احنا ما نشرب عندنا
فبالتالي لا تشيل هم، احنا مو زي بَرة
عندنا النَّاس راح تِجي تأكل
مو لازم تيجي تأكل وتشرب مع بعض
ما تشيل هم المعادلة هذه نهائيًّا
راح نقدم لهم مشروبات لكن غير كحولية
أو نخترع مشروبات غير كحولية
الرجل ما استوعب كثير
قلنا له: لازم ندعيك للسعودية
دعيناه على السعوديَّة وجاء في زيارة عمل على السعوديَّة
وأخذناه حوالين المطاعم الموجودة
في فندق الفيصليَّة المطعم الإيطالي اللي تحت
«لكوتشيني» إذا ماني غلطان كان اسمه
وفي مجموعة مطاعم فكان عشان يفهم قصَّة الأفراد والعوائل
وعشان يفهم أن في مطعم، ونتعشى فيه، وما فيه كحول
وتلك الفترة أتذكر أنت قلت لي أن يمكن بس في ثلاثة مطاعم اللي...
ثلاثة مطاعم
في الرِّياض تعتبر مطاعم
بالضبط
مرتَّبة
في مطعم «روما» مثلًا معروف، وكلنا تعودنا وربينا عليه
ومن محبينه إلى اليوم
فأخذناه مجموعة المطاعم المتوفرة «الخزامى»
«إنتركوت»
«إنتركوت» وبالفيصلية المطعم، إذا ماني غلطان
«لكوتشيني» الإيطالي اللي تحت، اللي الآن محله موجود «مامو»
و«روما» هذه الثلاثة هي اللي عليها...
هي ثلاثة أو أربعة مطاعم
ما حاولنا نشتته لأن هذه الموجودة عندنا
وديناه المطاعم بس عشان يفهم أفراد وعوائل
ويفهم موضوع أن احنا تشغيل جاف
ما عندنا مطاعم جافَّة، ما عندنا هذا
فهم واستوعب
كان عنده بعض النِّقاط
أن أنتم ماخذين 1100 كبير
طيب، لو ما جاؤوا أفراد راح يجلس فاضي، وعوائل
قلنا له: احنا متفهمين وجهة نظرك كمصمم
لكن لازم تسوِّي هذا الشيء
هذه المتطلبات
هذه المتطلبات، وأن لازم نسوي هذا الشيء
قلنا له: بابين
قال: ليش بابين جنب بعض؟
فقلنا له واحد للأفراد وواحد للعوائل
قال: هم الاثنين جنب بعض
المهم فكانت في قصص جدًّا مضحكة
أن نشرح...، طبعًا هو ما يستوعب
واحد جاي من برة ما عمره مر بالشيء هذا نهائيّا، ما يستوعبه
احنا غير استيعبنا له
فالحمد للَّه، تسهلت وسوِّيناه، صمم لنا المطعم
والحمد للَّه، كان النَّاس أقارب وأصحاب اللي يعزوا علينا
كانوا ينصحونا
أن يا جماعة ترا أنتم حاطين مبلغ كبير في ذاك الوقت كلف تقريبًا
أنت قاعد تلطفها أبو عبد الله
النَّاس ما كانوا يتكلمو بهذه الطريقة
النَّاس كانوا يقولون أنتم مهابيل
كانوا يقولون أنتم مهابيل
ما أحد يحط 20 مليون على مطعم
ما حد يحط 20 مليون على مطعم فكانوا يقولون أَنتُم مهابيل
أَنتُم بالحجم وبالكبر هذا
مسويين التَّجهيزات، ومسويين تجهيز دي جي مباشر
والتوصيلات ومكبر صوت عشان تعطيك نظام صوت
كُلَّه ماخذينه في الاعتبار
والمشروبات ما أحد كان يسويي
احنا أول مطعم في ذاك الوقت اللي كان يسوي موكتيلز
اللي هي مو كوكتيل، موكتيلز
بأنواع مرَّة كثير، جايبين مُختصين
وإلى آخره فكان خطوة كبيرة
والحمد للَّه، توفقنا، وفتح المطعم
الحمد لله، حسب دراسات الرؤية حقَّتنا والإقبال
احنا كنا متحفظين جدًّا في دراستنا
لأنّ كمان نكون منطقيين، هذه أول مرَّة
فالحمد لله، كانت أفضل من توقعاتنا لما فتحنا المطعم
وكان الإعلان الشَّفهي تطلع، والكلمة تطلع تنتشر
لأنّه في ذاك الوقت مواقع التَّواصل ما كانت منتشرة بالانتشار هذا
ما كان فيه سناب شات، وإنستقرام موجود بس على استحياء
ومو عندنا في السعوديَّة
فيسبوك مو عندنا في السعوديَّة
النَّاس المتابعين ممكن مناطق أخرى
بس مو في التركيز عندنا في السعوديَّة
فكنَّا نعتمد في التَّسويق على الإعلان الشَّفهي
تجربة النَّاس نفسهم
تجربة، ويروح أول ما يرجع البيت يقول لأهله
وثاني يوم يقابل أخوياه راح يقول لهم ولصاحباتها، وإلى آخره
فكان الإعلان الشَّفهي هي سبب الانتشار
فأخذ وقت إلى أن نشوفه يطلع ويتدرَّج في الطلوع
متى تحولتوا إلى الربحية؟
أنتم بدأتم في أغسطس 2014
احنا بدأنا سبتمبر 2014 طال عمرك
خلصنا 2015، من 2015 بدأت الشَّركة تبدأ في الربحيَّة
2016 مرجع رأس مالك؟
2016 تقدر تقول مو مرجع رأس مالك
بس نوعًا ما إي خلاص، تقريبًا هناك
والـ20 مليون
بدأنا نتوسَّع
رجَعَت؟
إي الحمد لله، بدأنا من خلالها نتوسع
ما شاء الله
بدأنا من خلالها نتوسَّع، فتحنا في...
يا سلام على البداية الوردية، ويا سلام على الأرقام
فكان في حماس، طبعًا بعدين في نقطة مهمة
لمن جاءت رؤية 2030، وبدأت الأمور توضح بوضوح كامل
وقطاع سياحة وقطاعات كثيرة بدأت
فاحنا كشركة الآن بدأت تفكر باستراتيجية
ففي الرؤية واضحة جدًّا، والاستراتيجية واضحة جدًّا
احنا الآن لازم نتماشى
وأنت كشركة تبغى تربط نفسك مع التَّوسع
فبالتالي اللي حطينا خطة توسعيَّة
وحطينا خطَّة كانت هي ما تزال شغف
بس كانت شغف خالص، أصبحت شغف مع استثمار طويل الأمد
وكل الخطط اللي انحطَّت خطط إلى طويلة الأمد
ولم تبنى الخطَّة على سنتين أو ثلاثة أو أربعة أو خمسة بما تتوافق
فبدأنا في محاكاة المطاعم، ونشوف أيش أشياء المطاعم
بدأنا نأخد، طال عمرك، نشوف أيش القوانين، وأيش العُرف؟
اتضح لنا أن أشياء كثير لما تيجي تقرأ في النظام هي غير موجودة
لكن هي عرف أصبحت بمثابة نظام
على سبيل المثال، باب أفراد و باب عوائل، هو عرف وليس النِّظام
كانوا يشرطوا عليك، ويقولوا لك أن لازم لمَّا تبحث تنزل تحت في القانون
لا، في مخارج لها أن ما فيه
موضوع جلسة العوائل وجلسة الأفراد
ترى هي ما كانت بالنظام بالوضوح أن يجب عوائل ويجب...
هي كانت عرف، سبحان الله، تحول إلى نظام
فهذه الأشياء لما بدأنا، فبدأنا حتى نسوي مطاعمنا الجديدة
أن نلغي، سوينا «نزومي» في جدة، طال عمرك
باب واحد، ما عاد فيه
وقلنا: ماخذين المخاطرة ماخذينها
ولمَّا جينا قدمنا على البلدية عشان نأخذ الرخصة، قدمنا عادي
جاءت الرخصة
ما أحد تفلسف، وما أحد جاء قال وين باب العوائل وباب الأفراد؟
جوَّا المطعم سوّيناه يمين ويسار، ومفتوحين على بعض
قلنا لو جاء سألنا فين؟ قلنا: هذا اليمين أفراد يا أخي وهذا اليسار...
بس ليش الفصل، ليش لازم أسوي جِدار؟
والحمد لله، ما صار، فأخذنا الخطوات الجريئة
في الرِّياض بدأنا نشيل الستار اللي كانت تفصل
لو تتذكر في «نزومي» كان فيه ستار يفصل عند بار السوشي
ستاير تنزل، شلنا الستاير هذه
قلنا راح نأخذ الخطوة هذه، ونشيل الستاير
على أساس النَاس تبدأ تشوف بعض
ما جاءتنا ملاحظات، لقينا زيادة إقبال
مع إنكم خسرتوا شريحة المحافظين ما عاد يرتاحوا يجون
لأنَّ...
شريحة المحافظين أو النَّاس اللي تنضغط، ما يزال يجي
ما خسرنا أحد، طال عمرك هي كانت عرف وقناعة
بس مجرد أنه يجرب أن أنا لو رحت للمكان هذا، وما في شيء عيب
وما تغير علي شيء
بس تتذكر أيش أشهر كلمة في ذيك المرحلة؟
حاجز
كان عندنا حاجز
في عندنا صالات اللي هي الحفلات الخاصَّة
صالات العشاء الخاصَّة كان اسمها
فالعوائل المحافظة كانت تفضل إنها تروح هناك
إي، كانت تروح هناك أو تجيب لها حاجز
احنا كنا نتحاشى عشان ما نبغى الثَّقافة حقَّت الحواجز يجي للمطعم
وكانت تجينا مخالفات، مخالفات شكوى من الزَّبون العميل
أن طلب حاجز، وتأخروا علي أو قالوا لي للأسف ما في حاجز
فييجينا زيارة من المفتشين، يقولوا في شكوى عليكم
ما يذكروا لك الاسم كل شيء سرِّي
في شكوى عليك أنه طُلب حاجز، وأنتم ما أعطيتوهم حاجز
لا في حاجز، يمكن صار سوء فهم
أحيانًا ترى يصير سوء فهم، أنا مو قصدي أن هذا...
يصير فيه سوء فهم من الأجنبي مو فاهم
احنا وظَّفنا كثير أجانب أروبيين
ترى حتى بالنسبة لهم، أوَّل ما جاؤوا السعوديَّة، ما هم فاهمين
ما هم قاهمين أن ليش أجيب حاجز وليش أجيب...؟
يحاول يقنع الزَّبون أنَّه ما يحتاج حاجز
من حبنا وشغفنا للمكان، نبغاه يشوف المكان
نبغاه يشوف الدِّيكور، نبغاه يستمتع بالمنظر
أحسن من أنه يقفل على نفسه
بس هذا خياره، رغبته الشَّخصية
رغبته الشَّخصية على العين والرأس
بس يمكن رغبته من أنَّه تعوَّد
من أنه مستحي، أنه هو تعود على كذا
لكن إذا قلت له أنا ما أجبلك الحاجز بس جرِّب
ولو نص ساعة أو ساعة، وما أعجبك أجبي لك الحاجز
فأنت تعطيه الفرصة أنه احتمال يغير في قراره
وفعلًا بعد فترة ترى ما كمَّلنا أقل من سنة
ما عاد فيه عندنا ولا حاجز في المطعم
يبقى عندنا واحد أو اثنين احتياطًا لأنه شروط
لو أحد اشتكى وما هو موجود عندنا، فكان موجود عندنا
بس هذه كانت موجودة
بعدين طال عمرك أخذنا خطوات استباقية
كنَّا وقت الصلاة نطلب من الزبون الموجود اللي يأكل
أن نجي ننبههم ترى بعد ربع ساعة بنسكر عشان الصَّلاة، فنستأذنكم
أنه لازم الجميع يطلع، ممنوع أحد يبقى
بعدين نسكر الباب، وما نستقبل أحد وقت الصلاة
بعدين جلسنا نفكر قلنا: هل من المنطق أنه نطلب من واحد قاعد يأكل
نقول له وقت الصلاة، عجِّل في أكلك واترك
ترى حتَّى ديننا مو كذا، حتى لو أنت في البيت، وأذَّن وأنت قاعد تأكل
من السُّنَّة أنك تخلِّص أكلك، وبعدين تصلِّي
ولا تقطع أكلك، وتقوم تصلي، وترجع مرَّة ثانية
حتى لو بحثنا في هذا الشيء
فبالتالي أيش اللي صار؟
اللي صار بأنَّنَا أخذنا خطوة، اللي قاعد يأكل ما يصير، خلوه يأكل
عندنا سجادات في الغرفة المخصصة، السجاد موجود
وقت ما هو يبغى يقوم يطلب يصلي، يصلي
سكر الباب، صح ما تستقبل، بس اللي جوَّا، وقاعد يأكل يكمل أكله
ما يصير إنك تجي...
فأخذنا هذه الخطوات لأن احنا ربطناها
بأن، مرة ثانية، فيه العُرف وفيه الشيء المكتوب موجود عندنا وكلنا نعرفه
وكلنا متفقين عليه
والحمد للَّه، ما واجهنا أي شيء
وقت الأذان على طول نسكِّر الموسيقى
بعدما تخلِّص الصَّلاة، نرجع نرفع الموسيقى
النَّاس كانت تعجبهم موضوع الموسيقى أن في موسيقى
لأن الموسيقى يا سيِّدي الفاضل، قصتها
كيف بدأت في المطاعم برّة في الخارج؟
كانت هي اللي تعطي الخصوصيَّة بين الجلسات
احنا مجموعة خمسة، وجالسين نحكي بصوت عالي
تخيل لو ما في موسيقى
أنت مسموع من الطاولة اللي جنبك وأزعجناهم
مو بس مسموع، وأزعجناهم
وسواليفهم هم كمان جالسين احنا نسمعها
فما احنا قادرين لا نأخذ راحتنا احنا في السَّواليف
لأن تتلخبط السواليف مع بعض، ولأنهم قريبين من بعض
الموسيقى كانت تعطي الخصوصيَّة الصَّوتية بين الطاولات
وهذا النَّجاح أبو عبد الله اللي فوق التوقعات، ما شاء الله
في أول بداية لكم اللي هو «نزومي»
أدى إلى خطوتين
الخطوة الأولى أنَّكم سوِّيتوا «نزومي» للحفلات والطلبات الخارجية
صحيح، للحفلات والطلبات الخارجية
وسويتوا مقهى «إِيرث»
مقهى «إِيرث» طال عمرك
علمنا بشكل موجز عن الخطوتين هاتين
نعم.
لأن هذول هم صاروا في 2015 بدأ العمل عليهم
بدأ العمل عليهم في 2015 مباشرةً
احنا بدأنا العمل مباشرةً في النصف الثاني من 2015
بدأنا نقول طيب الخطوة الجاية، بدينا في كاترينق
فكانت تجينا طلبات للكاترينق وطلبات خاصَّة
وما كان عندنا التأهيل في المطعم
أن يكون عندنا فريق متخصص في كاترينق
وكان أن الاستثناء يطلعوا الفريق من المطعم ومن المطبخ
يطلعوا يقوموا يأدوا كاترينق، ويرجعوا مرَّة ثانية
طبعًا يا تدفع لهم للوقت الإضافي، وإلى آخره
لأن اشتغلوا إلى ساعات متأخرة
بعدين قلت طيب هذه الطَّلبات ما احنا قاعدين نسوق لها
وتجينا طلبات خاصة معيَّنة من زبائن معينين، وإلى آخره
ليش ما نبدأ نفكر فيها كنموذج عمل تجاري؟
أن هذا العمل بدأنا نفكر فيها في كاترينق
كانت الخطة الأولى،
احنا نبغى نسوِّي كاترينق بس طبيعة الطَّعام الياباني
أنت ما تقدم سخانات، وتحطَّها في بوفيه
لا، هي فيها تحضيرات، وفيها طبخ حي في المكان
طيب معناته نبغى محطَّات
والمحطَّة نبغاها على نفس الديكور حّق «نزومي»
فتم تفصيل محطَّات كاملة، وقتها صمَّم لنا إياها
وتم تصميمها، لقينا مكان يصمِّمها، ويصنِّعها في لندن
تم تصميمها بالكامل، جبناها
وجبنا الشَّاحنة، وكانت معدَّات ثقيلة
وكنا نسوي كاترينق مرة كثير
سوينا في بيوت خاصة حفلات عشاء خاصَّة ، وإلى آخره
نفس التَّجربة اللي تأخذها في المطعم بالطاولات
أقدام قابلة للطَي، الطاولات اللي هي تتطبَّق بس نفس الخشب
ونفس الكراسي بس تنطوي عشان تتجمع وتروح وتنحط
فأنت تأخذ الـتَّجربة اللي تأخذها في المطعم
تأخذها في الحفلة الخاصة أو مكانك الخاص مزرعة
بس ما كملتوا ليش؟
تكلفة التَّشغيل
2000 على الشَّخص، أنتم كنتوا أغلى كاترينق
ويالله، هذا مع العلم أنه ما كانت تغطِّي التَّكاليف، رقم واحد
رقم اثنين لأن أنت عندك تكلفة عمل ثابتة لمَّا تعيِّن موظَّفين
فأنت معناته تكلفة ثابتة إذا ما جاءك كاترينق
فأنت ربحك صفر، وعندك تكلفة ثابة جالسة تطلع
الشيء الثاني وهؤلاء طُهاة، وكلهم ومقدمين خدمة
لأن يطلعوا طُهاة، ويطلعوا خدمة اثنين مع بعض الفريق
الشيء الثاني بدأت المطاعم
بدأت النَّاس صارت تحب تطلع المطاعم أكثر
فخف الطَّلب صار كل أحد يبغى يطلع برَّة
صار الكل يبغى يطلع برَّة مع التَّغييرات والموسيقى في المطاعم
المطاعم ما عاد صار فيها عوائل وأفراد، وصارت عادية
مطاعم زي الكويت زي أي منطقة ثانية، مطاعم طبيعية
فبالتالي الكل صار يبغى يطلع من بيته
والعزايم صارت تصير في المطاعم
طبعًا هذا أفادنا احنا فيه مشروع المطعم، لأن احنا الأساس هو المطعم
وليس برَّة، وخف الطَّلب على كاترينق
صار الطَّلب كاترينق استثنائي جدًّا
مناسبات خاصة أو زواج أو خطوبة أو عرس بسيط
أو ملكة أو غيره أو أيًا كانت المناسبة
في مزارع او في بيوت، وإلى آخره، وتكلفتها تظل جدًّا عالية
والله ركَّزنا قلنا خلاص كاترينق نبغى نوقفه
اليوم احنا موجود عندنا كاترينق، بس بطريقة مختلفة
ما عاد فيه المحطَّات اللي احنا نوديها
احنا نروح لكاترينق إذا أنت عندك المطبخ مُجهَّز في المزرعة أو في البيت
فنضطر نستخدم مطبخك
بس نقل العِدَّة، أجهزة الطَّبخ كانت جدًّا متعبة
وما هي عمليَّة
فنسوي كاترينق استثنائي جدًّا اليوم بس بطريقة مختلفة
وفي نفس الوقت برضو كنتوا شغالين على مقهى «إِيرث»
في نفس الوقت...
ليش ما كان تحت الشَّركة؟
كنتوا شركة منفصلة
نعم لأن شريكنا، طال عمرك، «أبو فيصل» يعطيه العافية
هو اللي دلَّنا على...
من «أبو فيصل»؟
الأمير «عبد الله بن نايف» دلَّنا...
من أوائل السعوديين اللي سكنوا في...
أو تملَّكوا منزل في كاليفورنيا
ودائمًا يقضي إجازته الصيفية هو والعائلة، الله يحفظهم، في كاليفورنيا
فجاء، طال عمرك، وفي معرفة
جاء بلَّغنا قال: يا جماعة مقهى «إِيرث» في كاليفورنيا
ليش ما نجيب مقهى «إِيرث»؟
طيب حسنًا، شفنا وبحثنا عن مقهى «إِيرث» وإلى آخره
هو فقط للطعام وللفطور ولمقهى ولحلويَّات
للعشاء أو للغدا أو للسلطَات وللطعام الصِّحي
مقهى عضوي أو للشاي عضوي، وإلى آخره
الصراحة فكرة جدًّا جميلة
فقط موجودين في كاليفورنيا
وقَّعوا في اليابان، في ذاك الوقت
بس ما بعد فتحوا في اليابان
فقط في كاليفورنيا
حتى في أمريكا، لم يتوسعوا خارج كاليفورنيا نهائيًّا
تباحثنا وإلى آخره، طيب، ممتاز
فسوِّينا شركة تملكها شركة المأكولات العصرية «إم إف سي»
و«أبو فيصل»
الشَّركة هذه، عرَّفنا هو على المُلَّاك للشركة ووقعنا معهم حق امتياز
للسعودية والإمارات والبحرين وقطر
كانت الكويت موقَّعة
وما وقعنا عُمان في ذاك الوقت
فقط فوقَّعنا السعوديَّة والثلاث دول المجاورة
والحمد لله، كانت بداية موفقة
فتحتوا في 2017؟
في مايو 2017 فتحنا أول مقهى «إِيرث» اللي في التَّحلية
ومقهى «إِيرث» برضو كان مختلف عن كاليفورنيا
لأنه عندهم برضو قصَّة مختلفة في المصممين
طلبنا من مقهى «إِيرث» المُصمم اللي عندهم يتعاملوا معه
طلع بروفيسور بدوام جزئي، يشتغل في أوقات الفراغ
هو بروفيسور في الجامعة، مهندس معماري ومصمم في الجامعة
لما تعاملنا معه
قلنا، مرة ثانية، هل احنا نبغاه نفس مقهى «إِيرث» هذاك يمشي في أمريكا
مو شرط اللي يمشي في أي مكان أو في بلد معينة أو في مدينة معينة
بالضروري بنفس التَّصميم يمشي عندنا
فقلنا لا خلنا نشوف خيارات أخرى
وتكلمنا معاه وسوينا وبدأنا بدايات بسيطة فقط
كنا مرة في «كويا» في دبي
جالسين نتعشى، ونطالع قلنا: والله حلو الديكور اللي هنا جميل وإلى آخره
مين المصمم هذا؟ تعرفنا عليه لقيناه
«ساقرادا قروب» «ريتشارد» المصمم وكلَمناه
قلنا له: نبغى نسوي معاك مقهى
قال: أنا سوِّيت مطاعم كثيرة، أنا سويت كل الـ«إل بي إم» اللي في العالم
سويت كل «كويا» اللي في العالم
سويت مطاعم مرة كثير، بس مقهى!
سويت فنادق، بس مقهى ما قد سويت
قالوا طيب هذه مقهى «إِيرث» في كاليفورنيا مختلفة
التفكير مختلف، أنه البيت وطبيعي وعمره أربعين سنة
فيه تاريخ وفيه قصَّة خلفه
هو ليس مقهى عادي مثلما أنت تفكر
قلنا له تعرف... هو من بريطانيا، ساكن في لندن
قلنا له تعرفه؟ قال لا، ما أعرف مقهى «إِيرث»
لم أذهب مسبقًا إلى مقهى «إِيرث»
قلنا له: احنا عازمينك
روح بنقطع لك تذكرة، ونحطك إقامة لمدة أسبوعين
تزور مقهى «إِيرث»
راح يستقبلونك هناك الجماعة
وبي قلنا له احنا عزمينك روح
نقطع لك تذكرة، ونحطك إقامة
لمدة أسبوعين تزور إيرث مقهى بيستقبلونك هناك الجماعة
وراح يأخذوك على كل فروع مقهى «إِيرث»
وتفهم وتستوعب العلامة التجارية
راح وجلس، طبعًا ما رفضها يعني رحلة أسبوع ببلاش
أسبوع ببلاش من لندن لكاليفورنيا
راح استمتع، ورجع، قال وافقت، راح أصمم لكم مقهى «إِيرث»
قلنا له: ممتاز
مقهى «إِيرث» هو مُتمدِّد، ونبغى نتوسَّع فيه
قلنا له عشان يكون عندك التَّصور هذا من اليوم الأول
احنا بنوقع معك اتفاقيَّة نموذجيَّة
وقَّعنا معاه إتفاقيَّة نموذجيَّة لكل مقهى «إِيرث»
من الأكشاك الصُّغار
الفروع المؤقَّتة
الفروع المؤقَّتة والصغيرة إلى الفروع الكبير
حسنًا، لأن نبغى من البداية يبدأ يفكر
أن الفرع الثاني لا يشبه الأول لكن فيه لمسات
نفس الرُّوح
ما يبدأ يفكر في واحد، وما يفكر في المستقبل
فيعمل حساباته من البداية فوقَّعنا اتفاقيَّة نموذجيَّة
مع أن يصمم لنا «إِيرث»
وفعلًا راح، والحمد للَّه، فتحنا مقهى «إِيرث»
في بداية التَّحلية قريب من الضَّباب
كأول مقهى «إِيرث» هذا كان في مايو 2017
اليوم، الحمد لله، كملنا أكثر من ستة سنوات
ما شاء الله، أربعة عشر فرع
الآن أربعة عشر فرع في مقهى «إِيرث» إجمالي
بما فيهم دبي وجدة والخبر والرياض
وكم فرع لـ«نزومي»؟
«نزومي» في ذاك الوقت؟
إي
«نزومي» فتحنا في الرياض وجدَّة
وسوينا أول في شتاء طنطورة في 2019
سوينا افتتاح «نزومي» مؤقت هناك
وتشرَّفنا بزيارة سمو سيدي ولي العهد فيه
هذه نجيها المواسم
بس أنا أتكلم الآن في 2017 في الوقت اللي أنت مبسوط
وقاعد تسوي هذه النَّجاحات، وتجمع هذه الفلوس، ما شاء الله
من كل زاوية
لا
أنت ما وزَّعت
ولا ريال ما توزع من يوم ما تأسست
فلا تجيب الطَّاري ترى شركائي الآن يجوا
بس في مردود عالي، ما شاء الله تبارك الله
قاعد يتحقق، ويُعاد استثماره في الشَّركة
يعاد استثماره بالكامل، ونحط فوقه
في هذا الوقت اللي أنت قاعد تسوي عوائد هائلة، ما شاء الله تبارك الله
تكتشف أن مطعم
عوائد هائلة، كمِّل طيب
رجعته في سنة واحدة، أيش تسمي هذا؟
لا هي ما هي كذا، عادلت الاستثمار، وكان ينحط
قراركم، ولا كان بإمكانكم توزعونه
لا، احنا نبغى نستثمر لأن زي ما قلت لك في البداية
لما شفنا خطة الرؤية 2030
هذا أكبر مُحمس ودافع يخليك أنك تطور، وما تفكر في توزيع الأرباح
ولا تفكر في الكلام الفاضي
بس في نفس الوقت كان يجيكم كلام من جدَّة والشَّرقية
بأن مطعمكم «نزومي» قاعد يوقع مع...
في «نزومي»؟
وكلاء آخرين
هذه صارت فعلًا، أن جاءنا في جدة أوَّل
أن مطعم «نزومي» قاعد يوقع
أنا لما عرفت رفعت السماعة على «أبو سعود»
من غير ما نذكره عشان ممكن ما يبغى «أبو سعود»
قلت له «أبو سعود» أَنتُم كذا؟
قال إي فيصل كذا، قلت: لا أبو سعود...
لأخوي فهد، قلت له: يا «فهد» انتبه ترى احنا موقعين السعوديَّة
قال تمزح يا فيصل، قلت: والله العظيم
قال لي طيب فيه مانع على الاتفاقيَّة؟
قلت: لا، طبعًا هذه النُّسخة من الاتفاقيَّة، تفضل
فالمطعم الأُم وقَّع معاهم
وقَّع معاهم
مع «فهد» ورغم أنه أنتُم تملكون الحق الحصري في السعوديَّة
السعوديَّة كِذا مذكورة
واضحة وضوح الشَّمس، لكن سبحان الله النَّوايا
شافها «فهد» قال لي معقول هذه واضحة وضوحة الشمس
شلون يخل بالعقد؟
كيف يخل بالعقد، وكيف يلعب علينا؟
قلت له بس انتبه
راح فهد يطالب الرجال بفلوسه، قال له أعطني الفلوس اللي دفعنا لك إياها
أنت أخليت...، طبعًا فص ملح، وذاب، اختفى الرجال
ما عاد له وجود
عيَّن فهد محامي يلاحقه لأن العقد موقَّع على القانون البريطاني
تعرف هو مقرَّه في بريطاني فيوقع على بريطاني
فلازم يعيّن محامي هناك
فعيَّن محامي هناك يلاحقه ما في فايدة ما قدروا يلاحقوه
ولا يجيبوا شيء خلاص
الله يعوِّض
الله يعوِّض بعد فترة يجينا خبر أنه وقَّع في الخبر
كلمت لما جاني الخبر، أنا ما أعرف «عبد المحسن» معرفة مباشرة
فلما جاءني الخبر الأكيد أنه وقع في الخبر
فطلبت من المحامي بس أنه صياغة خطاب بسيط
نقول له أن لعلمنا أنه تم كذا ووقعتوا
ونحب أن ننوهكم بأن العلامة التِّجارية هذه موقعة مع شركة المأكولات العصرية
وأنَّ العقد يشمل المملكة العربية السعوديَّة
وليس مدينة الرياض أو مدينة مستقلة في السعودية
فهو يغطي السعودية كاملة
كلَّمنا الرِّجال، قال يا ابن الحلال أيش هذا؟
قال والله هذا الموضوع اللي صار
قال إي وقعنا احنا، قلت: وقعتوا؟
قال وقعنا، بس دفعتوا؟ قال دفعنا
قلت: لاحول ولا قوة إلا بالله، والموقع؟ قال اخترنا الموقع
وبدأنا كل شيء
قلنا: طيب ترى بس للمعلومية الموضوع واحد واثنين وثلاثة نفس الشيء
راحوا يتواصلوا معه وعيَّنوا محامي
فص ملح وذاب، ما عد فيه الرجال هذا
وهذاك قفَّل أصلًا المطعم الأساسي اللي في لندن
قفل في مايو 2015
احنا فتحنا في سبتمبر 2014 وكيف عرفنا أنه قفَّل؟
بالصدفة واحد من الزبائن، قال أنا توي جاي من لندن
«نزومي» لندن مسكر، قلنا: معقول مسكر، وشلون سكر؟
احنا حتى ما جاءنا بالعلم ولا الخبر، ولا بلَّغنا
لأن في الاتفاقيَّة عندنا، أيش تقول؟ بناءً على «نزومي» لندن
فكل شيء مرتبط بـ«نزومي» لندن
فهو ما يبغى يبلِّغنا لأنه مجرد أنه يقفل «نزومي» لندن
معناته أخل بالعقد معناته
ما فيه مرجعية
ما عاد لك حقوق
ما فيه مرجعية في العقد، لأن العقد يقول لك ارجع إلى «نزومي» لندن
سكر «نزومي» لندن، وما عنده إلَّا الفرع هذاك
لمَّا كلمناه وبلغناه، قلنا له أنه جاءنا خبر من بعض الزبائن
اللي جاؤوا من لندن يقولوا «نزومي» لندن مسكر
قال لا أنا مختلف مع المالك
والحين استأجرت موقع ثاني، وجالس أنقل
حسنًا، خلاص الرجال جالس ينقل
طبعًا هذه ما عاد صارت، وإلى يومك ما فتح «نزومي» لندن
عليه قضايا هناك، فبالتالي ما فتح
فالشاهد بالموضوع كانت قصة عجيبة
وهذه كانت شرارة تغيير العلامة التجاريَّة
لمَّا تواصلنا معاه على جدة، قلنا له أنت وقَّعت في جِدة
لا ما أدري أيش، أنا آسف اعتذرنا
قلنا: يا ابن النَّاس التجارة فيها أخذ وعطاء
وفيها أنك تغمض عينك، وتستسمح وتكمل
كملنا وقلنا خلاص كأنه ما صار شيء
وانسوا الموضوع ترى ما صار شيء لكن حطوا في بالكم أن ننتبه
من الأشخاص اللي زي كذا
لمَّا صارت الشَّرقية، قلنا لا
هذه نوايا سيئة ما هي بغلط
نوايا سيئة، احنا جِدة، ومشِّيناها عديناها
أنت سويتها
جيت أنت ما بتضيف للعلامة عندنا ولا شيء
لما فتح هو في قطر ما كان عنده «نزومي» لندن
ووقع في الفردان في كمبنسكي في قطر
الموظفين اللي عنده بقطر، احنا ما لنا نعلاقة ولا لنا مسؤولية
ولا لنا دخل ولا رسُوم ولا شيء
تدربوا عندنا موظفين، هو قال معلش يدربوا عندكم؟ وتدربوا عندنا ببلاش
ولا أخذنا منه ولا شيء، عشان خاطر العلاقة
العلاقة لأن الشراكة هي شراكة طويلة الأمد
فأنت تفكر فيها مع شريكك ما تفكر فيها في خلافات من البداية
أو عطني وأعطيك، وإلى آخره
فلما صارت الشَّرقية، وتأكدنا أن وقَّع، شفنا الأوراق
أرسلنا له خطاب رسمي
قلنا له هنا...
كانت هذه في أكتوبر 2017
إيقاف العقد لأسباب الخرق اللي أنت قاعد تسويها
الاختراقات أو الإخلال
اختراقات وإخلال، وكانت اختراقات كبيرة ما هي صغيرة
أنك توقع عقود وتخل بالعقد
فهو مو إخلال بسيط
صحيح
أولًا «نزومي» لندن لا وجود له، فالاتفاقية غير مفعَّلة
ثاني شيء نملك السعوديَّة، وأنت رحت تحاول تبيع جدة
ومثبته وتبيع الشِّرقية
طيب، والدَّعم صفر ولا فيه نظام
كل الأشياء اللي تنص عليها حق الامتياز هذه صفر ما هي قاعدة تجي
نص قائمة الطعام اللي تشوفه من اليوم الأول تطويرنا احنا
ما هو تطوير«نزومي» أبدًا ولا كان فيه «نزومي»
بالعكس اللي كنا الشَّد والجذب
أنه لمَّا نطور أشياء معينة اللي هي الأفضل مبيعًا اليوم في «ميازو»
واللي كانت في «نزومي» هذه تطويرنا احنا
ما أخذناها من أي جهة من عنده
بس عشان تكون على بيِّنة
لما صار هذه، أرسلنا له خطاب
وقلنا الآن لازم نشتغل على علامة تجاريَة جديدة
العلامة التَّجاريَة هذه تحل محل «نزومي»
فعيَّنا شركة متخصصة في العلامة التِّجارية
كانت متخصصة في مجال الأزياء بالتَّحديد
وليس في مجال المطاعم، في مجال الأزياء
شركة بوتيك صغيرة جدًّا
بوتيك مقرَّها في باريس في فرنسا
واشتغلنا معاهم مشروع أخذ تقريبًا سنتين
سنتين إلى أن سوينا علامة كاملة اسمها «ميازو»
و«ميازو» ما كان تغيير للعلامة أو تغيير اسم
سجَّلنا ميازو لأن في هدف عندنا والفكرة اللي عندنا موجودة
أن «ميازوا» بإذن الله، يطلع في كل مكان نقدر ننافس فيه
ونطلع فيه، إن شاء الله نطلع
وأنه تطلع علامة سعوديَّة اسمها «ميازو»
ما كان وقتها محدد الاسم بس أن يطلع علامة سعوديَّة تمثل..
لأنه جاتني الفكرة اللي هي الثَّانية
أن زي ما احنا قاعدين نجيب مطاعم من برَّة حق الامتياز
ونجيب مثلًا من دبي ونجيب...
ليش ما يطلع من عندنا احنا؟ ليش ما احنا نصدِّر؟
أيش ينقصنا؟ ما ينقصنا شيء
ذوق في الأكل؟ عندنا أحلى ذوق في الأكل
ذوق في الاختيارات، والحمد لله، عندنا
إدارة نعرف ندير، في شيء ينقصنا؟ ما في شيء ينقصنا
إذا كان عندك توجه واضح وخطة واضحة وصريحة
أنت تقدر تنافس حتى المطاعم الموجودة في لندن ولا في باريس
ولا في موناكو ولا في دبي، ولا أيًّا كان
في أي مدينةٍ كانت الموجودة من برَّة
احنا دائمًا نجيب من برَّة
لا، هذه المرة احنا نبغى نطلِّعها، ونبغى نسوِّي
فسوِّينا وسجَّلناها في سبعين...
سجَّلنا العلامة التِّجارية بجميع أشكالها في سبعين دولة
بحيث أن يتأكد من اليابان إلى أمريكا
عشان حتى ما أحد يقولوا أخذتوا الاسم نسخ من اليابان
الاسم تمامًا جديد ما له أي علاقة، ولا أُخذ من أي شيء
والحمد لله، أطلَقنَاه، الآن، إن شاء الله، في ديسمبر نكمل الثلاث سنوات
في ديسمبر، 2020
ما شاء الله تبارك الله، وهذا يمكن أهم اثنين
والثَالث هم ثالث العلامات اللي في المرحلة الأولى خليني أسمِّيها أنا
هو «سان كارلوا شكتي» صح؟
«سان كارلوا شكيتي» وقَّعنا اللي هو «سان كارلوا قروب»
اللي تملك «سنيور ساسي» اسمه «سان كارلوا قروب»
عندهم مجموعة مطاعم
«تشكتي، فومو، بوتيقا»
في بريطانيا عندهم سبعة وعشرين مطعم
بعلامات تجاريَّة مختلفة
هذه «سان كارلوا قروب»
احنا وقَّعنا مع «سان كارلوا قروب»
وأخذنا حق الأولوية لجميع مطاعمهم، جميع العلامات التجارية
بس قالوا لنا «سنيور ساسي» الآن ما نقدر نعطيكم إياه
لأنه كان فيه عندهم اتفاق أدبي
بين «كارلو» المالك لـ«سان كارلو»
وبين «الخرافي» الله يرحمه، في ذاك الوقت، أمريكانا
فقال حتى لو ما فتحوا بس أنا أستحي أني أروح أطلبه
أنه يعطيني تَخلِّي فخلِّيها، لمَّا صارت الوفاة
تواصل معانا قال الآن خلاص تقدر تأخذ الاتفاقيَّة
لأنه ما في أحد بس أنا كان بس أدبي وشفهي بيني وبينه، وأنا محترم هذا الشيء
احنا حَمَّسنا أنه نشتغل معاه أكثر
لأن لقينا رجل يقدر أدبيات الشراكات
مقارنة بالشَّخص الآخر
إي، ما في مقارنة
فلقينا أنه هذا الشخص يقدر، أعطى كلمة
تخيل، ما بيني وبينه عقد بس عشان أعطاه كلمة
وقال لا يمكن أرجع له أو أكلمه أو أرفع عليه السماعة
أو أحطه تحت ضغط
فهذا شخص تقدره
فتحتوه عام 2016
فتحتنا «تشكتي» في محل «نزومي» حق الكيترنق لمَّا شفنا
لمَّا قفلتوه
لمَّا قفلناه قلنا طب الموقع عندنا
وعندنا عقد، فليش ما نحط فيه «تشكتي»؟
مرة ثانية أَنتُم مركزين على نفس الشَّارع الضَّباب
مع أنه ذاك الوقت فتحت كثير مناطق جديدة وجميلة
تركي الأول بدأ الحراك عليه، وبدأ النَّاس يلتفتون له
التَحلية رجع يجدد نفسه
والفيصلية والمملكة بدأت ترجع تجدد نفسها
صحيح
إلا إنكم متمسكين بهذا الموقع، ليش؟
والله ما أدري نجاح «نزومي» كان في الموقع
يخليك تتحمس أنه تكمل نجاحك في نفس المنطقة، هذا واحد
سبحان الله، مكتبنا موجود فوق مقهى «إيرث» اللي في التَّحلية
هذا كان حلمي أستأجر المبنى كامل
فبالتالي يسهل علينا الإدارة
وعشان مكتبنا موجود هناك فنحس أنه خلاص متعودين على المنطقة هذه
وهذا اللي خلانا أنه...
وعندنا موقع موقعين إيجار
قلنا الآن شلنا «نزومي» كيترنق
طيِّب أيش نسوي في الموقع؟
فحطيتوا فيه المطعم
يا سلام، فحطينا فيه المطعم
على أساس، أن يستغل استغلال الموقع اللي هو موجود عندنا
والحمد للَّه، كان نجاح آخر، كمطعم إيطالي كان نَّجاح ممتاز
ما هو بنفس الشَّريحة حَقَّت «ميازو»
ولا «نزومي» في ذاك الوقت غير رسمي
هذول الثلاثة «نزومي» اللي صار «ميازو» و«تشِكتِّي» ومقهى «إِيرث»
هي فقط الرَّبحانة في الجروب
وعندك ستة علامات تجارية ثانية اللي جاءت بعدهم خسرانين
ليش هذولي الثلاثة يربحون، وليش الستة الآخرين قاعدين يخسرون؟
حسنًا، طبعًا هذوليك فتحوا في البدايات
فكان المعروض ما هو نفس المعروض اليوم
فالتَّوقيت خدمهم، توقيت السوق خدم الثلاثة الأولى
توقيت السوق خدم العلامات التجارية تلك
بعدين لما جاءت كورونا، هذه في 2020
جاءت كورونا آخر 2019
بس في 2020 لمَّا جاءت كورونا ومن بعد كورونا والمعروض اللي زاد
فأنت عندك أثر جائحة كورونا
خلصت كورونا لكن أثرها المادِّي المالي
هذا أثرها المالي نقطة وبعدين يجي المعروض، زاد
أنت في سوق حر ما تقدر تيجي تقول لشركات لا تفتح مطعم
أو ما تقدر تيجي تقول تسوِّي تقسيم
فبالتالي أي واحد يقدم على ترخيص مطعم
في النهاية اقتصاد حُر من حقه أنه يأخد تصريح ويفتح مطعم
هو صاحب القرار
فصار في معروض من القطاع الخاص
معروض مرَّة كبير، المعروض زاد بقوَّة
والطَّلب جالس يزيد بس بالتدريج
ما هي بنفس الوتيرة ونفس السرعة للمعروض
لكن في شيء ملفت مثلًا لما نشوف «بليونير» واحد من مطاعمكم
في البدايات كان واسطات عشان تقدر تدخل
«بليونير» يا طويل العمر أنا راح أفاجأك برقم أنت لن تتخيله
أكثر مطعم مر علينا يجيه اتصالات حجوزات يومي
كان أول ما فتح يجينا 4 آلاف اتصال في اليوم طلب حجز في «بليونير»
يا ساتر
تتخيل، لا «ميازو» ولا «سينيور ساسي» ولا «تشيكتي»
ولا أي مطعم ثاني وصل للرقم هذا
اليوم أفتح الباب، وأدخل، وألاقيه نصف فاضي
أيش اللي صار؟
ما أعرف، جرَّبنا العّرض بعدين لقينا تعليقات كثيرة أن العرض ممل ومتكرر
وقفنا العرض، لما وقفنا العرض الآن تيجينا طلبات أن رجعوا العرض
وكان يكلفنا 350 ألف في الشهر
في الشهر 350 ألف؟
إي، الشَّركة اللي جايبينها عشان تسوِّي العرض هي شركة في أسبانيا
فمعاشتهم وأكلهم وشربهم وكل شيء علينا
فما هو مبلغ رخيص، أنت تتكلم
فما ما أعرف صراحة
أيش الأخطاء اللي صارت في «بليونير»
أيش الدروس المستفادة من «بليونير»؟
أنتم كلفكم 35 مليون؟
تقريبًا 35 مليون «بليونير» كلَّف
الدروس شوف أكون صادق معاك
أنا ما عرفت أيش الأخطاء اللي صارت إلى اليوم
فبالتالي ماني عارف أيش الدروس
احتمال أن الحجم الكبير ما ينفع كمطعم
كم كرسي فيه هو؟
تقريبًا 200 كرسي
مقارنة مع «شكيتي» كم كرسي؟
130 كرسي
ودائمًا مليان «شكيتي»
ودائمًا مليان بس حاشرين الكراسي جنب بعض
هل المساحة الملمومة والناس...؟
السعر
والسِّعر، حسنًا
والسعر في «شكيتي» أقل من «بليونير» أقل من «ميازو»
أقل من «سنيور ساسي»وغيرها من المطاعم، فهو يعتبر غير رسمي أكثر
من أنه يعتبر فاخر، لكن الجودة اللي جالس يعطيك إيَّاها نفس الجودة
اللي جالس يعطيك إياها في «سنيور ساسي»
المكوِّنات اللي نستخدمها، هي نفس المكوِّنات
وما نستخدم نوعين من المكوِّنات أو مستويين من المكونات
مكونات عالية الجودة، بس نزلنا من تكلفة تشغيل أقل لأن المطعم أصغر
فعدد الموظفين أصغر
بس ما رخَّصنا في المواد، هي نفس المواد
فبالنَّسبة للناس «شكيتي» قيمة من أجل المال
أنا أروح وفي قيمة إلى الوجبة حقَّتي اللي أكلها فجدًّا مبسوطين
دائمًا التَّعليق...
عندكم تجربة ناجحة، ليش ما تتكرر؟
ليش ما استهدفتوا هذه الشريحة؟
صحيح
جبتوا «سانيور ساسي» لشريحة...
«سانيور ساسي» ناجح، ما شاء الله تبارك الله، إلى اليوم
بس أنه ما يربح، التَّكلفة عالية
التكلفة عالية لأنه موقعه كبير ومطبخ جدًّا كبير
في« سانيور ساسي» يشتغل، طال عمرك، أربعة وثمانين طبَّاخ
أربعة وثمانين طبَّاخ؟
إي
ما يشمل طاقم الخدمة؟
بس خلف الكواليس في منطقة المطبخ
أربعة وثمانين
وكم اللي يشتغلون في تقديم الخدمة؟
المجموع 153 شخص يشتغل في «سانيور ساسي»
هذا اللي كلفكم 40 مليون؟
40 مليون
هذا هو السِّجل حقكم
لأنه هذه أرض مساحتها...استأجرنا أرض
احنا كل عقاراتنا، بس للتوضيح، ما نملك ولا عقار، كلها أجارات
حتى «سانيور ساسي» أرض استأجرناها طويلة الأمد
واستئجار طويل الأجل
وتم تطويرها على شكل فيلا
وجبنا «ريتشارد» وقلنا له من أول يوم نبغى نعطي التَّجربة البُندقيَّة
هو مطعم إيطالي
نبغى نسميه فيلا «سانيور ساسي»
ونعطيه التَّصميم أنه فيلا جايه مستوحاه من البندقية
فهو صمَّم، هذا «ريتشارد» اللي صمَّم لنا
صمّم فنادق في البندقيَّة في إيطاليا
فأخذنا التَّصميم والقطع الموجودة، وإلى آخره
والأشكال الهندسية من منطقة فنيسيا
لأنه مطعم إيطالي من منطقة فنيسيا في إيطاليا
فبنينا الأرض على هذا الأساس
وسوّينا لها موقف سيارات تحت، كل القّبو
مساحة الأرض 2700 متر
مباني 1100 متر مسطح وقبو كامل تحت
بهذا الحجم والتكلفة عمره ما راح يرجع رأس ماله
لو نزلت تكاليف العمالة
ما تقدر تشغِّل مطعم بالمستوى وبالأداء هذا
بقائمة طعام فيها 180 عنصر، فيها تنوع
كل يوم عندنا حجز كامل في العشاء، كل يوم من يوم ما فتح
ما زال؟
ما زال
ما شاء الله
من يوم ما فتح إلى اليوم
كل يوم في المساء، أيًّا كان أيام الأسبوع
الذَّروة تسة ونصف، إلَّا ما تلاقيه محجوز كامل
ما شاء الله
«كويا» كذلك فتح
«كويا» فتحناه
«كويا» لمَّا كان مؤقت في جدة كان عليه إقبال هائل
كان أكثر واحد نجح في موسم جدة
احنا في موسم جدة شغلنا «سنيور ساسي»
«نصرت» كافتتاح مؤقَّت، «زوما» و«كويا»
هذه الأربع مطاعم، وفتحنا مقهى «إيرث»
خمسة افتتاحات مؤقتَّة سوِّيناهم في موسم جدة في نفس الوقت، فتحناهم
لكن «إيرث» كان فاتح بالفعل في الرِّياض
فهذه أربع مطاعم فتحناها جديدة مِا كانت موجودة في السعوديَّة
أكثر واحد كان عليه إقبال وأكثر تعليقات كان يجيه «كويا»
ولما فتحتوه؟
لما فتحناه في «الدي كيو» فتحنا افتتاح مؤقت آخر
كان برضو افتتاح مؤقت في «الدي كيو» في عود سكوير كان عليه إقبال
بعدين قفلنا لما جاءت الكورونا
سكَّرناه، وخلص أنهيناه، وقلنا...
فتحتوا الفرع الدائم؟
وقعنا الاتفاقيَّة، وفتحنا الفرع الدَّائم
ما هو قاعد يحقق المطلوب
في البدايات حقق بعدين نزل الطَّلب شوي
ليش؟ المعروض زاد
بس في البدايات جَلس أوَّل ستة شهور محجوز بالكامل كُل يوم
يوميًّا، ما شاء الله تبارك الله، الطَّلب
«بييف بار» نفس الحكاية
«بييف بار» نفس الشيء
في شيء غريب
شوف النَّاس عندنا نوعًا ما
أيش اللي صار بعد 2019 بحيث أن كل هذه...
يعني مثلًا شوف باستثناء «بليونير» هو اللي تقييمه نازل مرة ، على فكرة
أنت تعرف الشيء هذا صح؟
أي
في قوقل تقييمه 3.5
صحيح
هو أقل عَلامة تجارية عندكم كتقييم
البقيَّة تقييماتها جيِّدة، بس تدخل تلاقيها فاضية
صحيح
وهذه الحالة تنطبق على أغلب المطاعم ما بعد مرحلة كورونا
كورونا كانت الذروة واسطات، ويُباع حجز الـ«بي إم» في حَراج
تدخل تشتري الحجز حق فلان
لأن لو بتحجز بنفسك راح تلاقي حجز بعد شهرين
صح
اليوم كل هذه تفتح الباب، وتدخل في نفس اللحظة، وتأخذ الكرسي
صحيح
أيش صار بعد 2019؟
الطَّلب، التَّنوع طلعت
ثاني شيء
مو الطَّلب، العرض
عفوًا، العرض
العرض
العرض ارتفع مرَّة كثير فجأة وبسرعة
أنا أعطيك، ما شاء الله تبارك الله
«البجيري» مجموعة جميلة جدًّا من المطاعم، ومنطقة جميلة جدًّا
فمن الطَّبيعي أنه فتحت منطقة كبيرة
وفيها مجموعة كبيرة من التَّنوع
ليسن فالي، ما شاء الله، منطقة جديدة ومُطوَّرة وفيها مجموعة من المطاعم
كافت، منطقة جميلة وفيها مجموعة من المطاعم
وجالسة تفتح فيها مجموعة من المطاعم
«مانسارد» عند فندق «الرميزان»
ما شاء الله تبارك الله، صار فيها مجموعة
فالرِّياض صارت...
«الخزامى» و«الفيصليَّة»
«الخزامى» و«الفيصليَّة» عفوًا
فيها الـ «بي إم» وفي «مامو» وفي «مراكي»
في مجموعة أسماء كبيرة
ڤيا رياض الآن برضو
ڤيا رياض الآن مؤخرًا هي آخر...
ڤيا رياض، ما شاء الله تبارك الله، جوَّا
فوق العشر مطاعم أو خمسة عشر مطعم موجود
وأسماء كبيرة جايين من كاليفورنيا
وجايين من أمريكا وجايين من أوربا، فأسماء كلها عالميَّة
فشيء طبيعي أنا فيصل وأنت عمر
احنا كزبائن نبغى نروح نجرب
أنا ما أقدر أكرر كل يوم نفس المكان، أمِل
فنروح نجرب، ونسحب على المكان القديم
فتسحب على المكان
ما تغير شيء في «بليونير»
النَّاس تقول إنه فجأة فاضي، تغير شيء أو صار شيء
هو ما تغير
النَّاس جالسة تجرب أماكن جديدة، هذا واحد
ثاني شيء هبَّة المطاعم خلينا نقول كذا بصراحة
النَّاس كلها فجأة تطلع
طبعًا مستثمرين بجميع أنواعهم فجأة استثمروا عشان هبَّة النَّاس
النَّاس في النهاية ملَّت الطلوع
صار طُلوعها معتدل
النَّاس بطبيعتها، الهبّة في البداية كان طلوع أكثر من...
هل كورونا غشّت النَّاس لأن مع حظر التجول...؟
غشت القرارات الاستثمارية، صح
الكل شاف المطاعم فل وطلب وزحمة
فالنَّاس تحمست، وهذول اللي فتحوا بعد سنتين من كورونا
خلاص النَّاس هديت
انصدموا
النَّاس هديت، شيء طبيعي
وناس سافرت وصارت مييزانيَّته الشَّخصية يسافر فيها
وما عاد في سُرعة
أنا الآن فاتح المطعم، إذا مارحته اليوم
تَرى أقدر أروحه الشهر الجاي أو أقدر أروحه بعد أسبوعين
أقدر أروحه بعد شهر
وكثرتها أحيانًا، سبحان الله، تخلِي الواحد قراره يمكن ما يروح ولا مطعم فيهم
لأنه لمَّا تكثر الخيارات يمكن قرارك يقول تدري؟
خلونا نجلس في البيت، ونجيب عشاء في البيت
هذا واحد من القرارات، فهذه كمان أثرت
في التأثير المباشر والغير مباشر
تأثير المنافسة المباشرة من المعروض
وفي غير المطاعم هذه تنافسك لأنهم نفس شريحتك
الأمسيات الغنائية، حفلة عبدالمجيد، أنت تتأثر كل المطاعم
المطاعم لما يكون في عندك حفلة، شي طبيعيء
النَّاس الحضور، ما شاء الله تبارك الله
التَّذاكر تُباع في أقل من نصف ساعة أو أقل حتَّى، أقل من عشر دقائق
والخيارات التَّرفيهية الأخرى صارت تأخذ من...
شريحتك
حُصَّة المطاعم
تأخذ لمن يكون فيه...
لأن المطعم جزء كبير منه أنه هو طلعة عائلية أو طلعة ترفيهيَّة
خصوصًا أَنتُم
بالضَّبط
الشريحة حقتكم
بالضبط الشريحة حقتنا فأنت نفسك ترى الشريحة، هذه واحد
الآن، ما شاء الله تبارك الله، نسبة المشاهدة كم ارتفعت في الكرة
الدوري السعودي؟
ارتفعت، أنا ما تحضرني النسبة، بس أضعاف نسبة المشاهدة كمشاهدة
صار عندنا لعيبة محترفين من الخارج
نسبة الحضور والمشاهدة التلفزيونية رهيبة، مو شرطة الحضور
فالمباريات كمان، ما شاء الله تبارك الله
بس هذه يغلب عليها الجمهور الرجالي
اللي ما هو جمهوركم الأساسي
أَنتُم الظاهر الشريحة الأساسية عندكم نساء، صح؟
إي بس أنت تتكلم ترى 45% رجال و55% نساء
مو كثير، ظينت أكثر
لا، والرجال ما تستهين فيهم
لأن الرجال، أنا أتكلم كعمل تجاري
المطعم مهم لأن...
يدفع أكثر
متوسِّط دفع الرَّجل أكثر من المرأة
تلعبون علينا، وتأكلوننا لحوم ودجاج ودسم
إي
وهم يأخذون حلى ومشروب
سلطات وحلى وأشياء بسيطة برضو السَّيدات فما فيه...
ما فيه ربحية من وراءهم
لا، فيه ربحية
الرِّبح من وراء ظهورنا احنا
والله وجود الجميع هو أكبر ربح
أكيد
وهو أكبر مكسب
بس أتكلم الحين كعمل تجاري صَافي، الرِّبح من الرجال
الرجال، الصَّرف عندهم أعلى من النساء
ما في كلام، في المطاعم
لأن، ما شاء الله، أكلهم أعلى
في كلام على موضوع المواسم
أن النَّاس تربط الهبوط اللي صار بالمواسم
المواسم صارت تجيب خيارات أكثر
صارت فترة الذَّروة، أجمل فترة في الرِّياض وفي جدة هي فترة الشِّتاء
احنا بلد أجمل ما فيه الشِّتاء
الصيف حر والناس ما تطلع أو تكون مسافرة
صحيح
ففي ناس تربط هذا الهبوط أو التَّراجع اللي صاير في المطاعم
بسبب وجود المواسم
ويقولون بأن المواسم فكرتها في أغلب الأماكن هي لتنشيط
الفترات الميتة
فتلاقي مثلًا وينتر ووندر لاند اللي في لندن
هو يصير في ذروة الشِّتاء
ذروة الشِّتاء
أسوأ موسم اللي النَّاس ما تبغى
تطلع ولا تبغى تروح الحديقة
صُنع هذا الفصل ليخلق حراك واقتصاد في الفترة الميتة
دبي راح تلاقي بداياتها كان مهرجان دبي للتسوق في فترة الصيف
لأنها فترة ميتة في دبي
لما جينا في السعوديَّة وفي رياض تحديدًا
حطينا موسم الرِّياض في فترة الذروة
اللي الرياض أصلًا عليها إقبال وحماس
وانحط الموسم في هذه الفترة الشتوية
وصار الاعتماد على النَّاس اللي برّة السوق
فالمطاعم اللي من برة تأتي تفتح لها فروع أو فعاليات مؤقتة
وهذه كلها أثرت سلبًّا على الموجودين في السوق
أيش رأيك في هذا الكلام؟
ما أثرت سلبًا بشكل دائم
قد تؤثر أنها تأخذ شريحة من عملائك بشكل مؤقَّت
لكن أثرها الإيجابي على المدى البعيد واضح وجدًّا
وأنا أقدر أثبت لك إياه الآن
اعطنا بالأرقام، كم تنزل مبيعاتكم في وقت الموسم؟
أحيانًا وقت الموسم يصير فيه هبوط 30%
%30 خلال الموسم
بشكل عام أنا أتكلم، بس مطعم عن مطعم يفرق
أكيد
بس أنا أتكلم بشكل عام
فهذا الهبوط ينزل
طيب على كامل السَّنة، كم الزيادة؟
على كامل السَّنة يفتح لك شريحة عملاء
أو شريحة ضيوف أو شريحة زبائن جديدة
لأنَّه اللي ساعد وخلَّى ثَقافة المطاعم تزيد والخروج من البيت
والمشاركة في الفعاليات المختلفة أو الاحتفال في مطعم
أو احتفال في عيد ميلاد في مطعم
أو بمناسبة ذكرى سنويَّة أو غيره
أيش ما كانت المناسبات الخروج والعزايم في المطاعم وإلى آخره
جزء كبير من هذه اللي ساعد فيها التَرفيه
لأنه المطاعم التِّجارية...
احنا أو غيرنا من الشَّركات
ما راح تغيروا سلوك النَّاس
ما تقدر تغير سلوك النَّاس
بس التَّرفيه غير من سلوك النَّاس
فزي ما أقول لك، التأثير إذا أنت تنظر لها تأثير وقتي، محدود
لكن على المدى البعيد، احنا قاعدة عملاؤنا
احنا عندنا مركز اتصالات الخاص بنا
وشيء جدًّا، إن شاء الله، في يوم من الأيام تيجي تزوره أوريك شيء مُبهر
إن شاء الله
الله يسلمك، الشرف لنا
كان عندنا تقريبًا 250 ألف
من بدأت المواسم ارتفعت وزادت
اليوم وصلت 550 ألف قاعدة عملاؤنا
الشَّريحة هذه كيف جاؤوا وإلى آخره؟
ترا اللي حرَّك النَّاس، وطلعهم من بيوتهم
وخلاهم يطلعوا يستمتعوا بكل ما هو موجود في السعوديَّة
والعروض الموجودة
أن اطلعوا من بيوتكم استمتعوا
ترا سوِّيناها يعني هذه كلها صارت للشعب للمواطنين والمقيمين
قبلما أنَّها بس عشان تستقطب من الخارج
السِّياحة داخلية صارت
فهذه كمان استفدنا احنا منها
فأنت تشوف مفهوم المواسم صحِّي
على المدى البعيد
على المدى البعيد بالقطاع
تخدمك، وما تنظر لها على المدى القريب
واللي يتكلمون على منافسة غير عادلة
من ناحية أن أنا صاحب مطعم قاعد أستأجر مستودع في الرِّياض
وأوظف عمالة، وأدفع لهم رواتب
وأخذ مسار طبيعي في الجمارك لاستيراد المواد حقتي
بعدين يجي مطعم مؤقت في الموسم ربحه مضمون
احنا شاركنا في المواسم
حسنًا
أنا ودي أعرف مين هذول اللي يأخذوها بربح مضمون
أقولك إياها، أشاركك فيها
هذه ما هي صحيحة المعلومة
تشارك أنت في الإيجار إمَّا بمبلغ أو بنسبة من مبيعاتك
فهذه تعتبر مشاركة في الإيجار
ما في شيء اسمه ربح مضمون أو احنا ما شفناه
احنا شاركنا في المواسم
بس أنت في السوق، أكيد أنك بتعرف إذا هذه معلومة صحيحة أو لا
لا
ما هي صحيحة؟
لا، ما هي صحيحة
فما أحد جاء بربح مضمون أو بدخل...
ما أحد جاب
إذا كان أخذ ودُفع بعض التَّكاليف لصاحب العلامة العالميَّة
وليس للشركة، صاحبة العلامة العالميَّة
غُطت بعض التَّكاليف من الموسم
هذا شيء استفاد منه صاحب العلامة العالميَّة
بس الشَّركة المحليَّة هو متحمل العمالة
ومِتحمل تَكاليف التَّشغيل وإلى آخره
فيه تحمل لمجموعة من النِّقاط هذه
لكن يمكن بعض النَّاس مفهوم أن هذا فاتح في الموسم
معناته أنه جاي بلاش
ما في شيء اسمه بلاش
فهذا مفهوم خاطئ وغير صحيح
إي مَدفوع في قيمته
أجل كلمنا عن تجربتكم أنتُم مع المواسم
شاركتم في موسم العلا وموسم الرِّياض وموسم جدة
شاركنا في موسم العلا 2019
شاركنا وكانت تجربة ممتازة
يأخذوا نسبة مِنَّنا من الربح
يشاركوك في الرِّبح مقابل تقديم الخدمات
مقابل تقديم الموقع ومقابل التَّسهيلات اللي تأخذها من خلال الموسم
هم يدفعوا لك تجهيز المكان؟
يعطوك مبلغ، وأنت تدفع من خلاله تجهيز المكان
فهم يعطوك مبلغ؟
إي يعطوك مبلغ عشان تجهيز المكان لأنه المؤقت، ما هو دائم
صح
فأنت لما تفتح شهرين أو ثلاثة أو أربعة هذا مؤقت
هل يعطوك تسهيل في العمالة؟
لا عمالتنا اللي راحت من عندنا
من عندكم؟
أي
هل يضمنوا لك مستوى دخل معين أو أرباح معينة؟
لا، أبدًا ولا حجوزات ولا أي شيء
أنت وشطارتك
والفريق اللي كان يطلع عندنا احنا في وقتنا في «نزومي» في طنطورة
كان يطلع الفريق من «نزومي» جدة
حسنًا
طلَّعنا فريق العمل
من «نزومي» جدة
لأنه أقرب
وهل كانت مربحة؟
في مجملها ربحنا بس مربح بسيط
المربح الأهم مشاركتنا والتَّسويق، أن احنا شاركنا هناك
لأنكم استمريتوا أنتُم إلى الآن موجودين
لا، احنا الآن موجودين بغير موسم طمطورة بعقد ثاني مختلف
وفاتحين في شادن، وندفع إيجار إلى شادن
شادن أصحابه شركة خاصة
وهل هو مربح؟
أقدر أقول لك مُتعادل
مُتعادل، ليش مستمر؟
لأن العقد اللي وقعته ثلاث سنوات
فأنت مٌتدبس؟
لا، مو متدبس
أنا ممكن أن هذا...
هل راح تجدد، لو انتهى عقدك؟
نهاية عقدي ينتهي على نهاية رمضان الجاي
هذا اللي جاي في عام مارس، 2024 أو أبريل
هل راح تجدد وللا لا؟
إلى الآن قرار التجديد، الله أعلم، ما أعرف
أيش تميل له؟
لو هو مُجدِي راح تجدد، لو هو مش مُجدِي ما راح تجدد
لو مُجدِي حجدد، لو غير مُجدِي لأن...
اكتملت الحين سنتين ونصف
أكيد أنَّه بيّن معاك هو مُجدِي وللا لا؟
أي، أنا أقول لك لو...
لأنه عمومًا أرباحنا في المطاعم الثَّانية جالسة تقل مع المنافسة
فتحتاج خطة
فيمكن الوضع المالي ما يسمح لي أني أجدِّد
فخلِّي قراري ما يكون عاطفي ولا يكون شخصي
قراري مبني بأيش إمكانيَّات الشَّركة ومقدرتها
حسنًا
وضع الشَّركة، وأنا كمدير تنفيذي للشركة وشريك إداري فيها
ما أتوقع أنه راح تقدر الشَّركة أنها تكمل إذا ما كان مجدي
هذه تجربتكم في العلا
موسم الرِّياض وموسم جدة، كيف كانت تجربتكم؟
موسم جدة كان جدًّا ممتاز
تأكيدًا للنقطة اللي أنت ذكرتها، موسم جدة كان في فترة الصيف
احنا كمشاركين في الموسم
وكانت التَّغذية الرَّاجعة اللي تيجينا من النَّاس، حر
يا جماعة مرَّة حر
فبالتالي، صارت المواسم تصير في الشتاء
لأن تجربة الصيف كانت رطوبة وحر
تطلع في عز الصيف وبعض النَّاس مسافرين كمان بالإضافة بالتالي
فبالتالي كان الإقبال كويس وممتاز لكن مو اللي كنا نطمح له
أيش طبيعة العلاقة مع المواسم؟
كنا فاتحين خمس مطاعم
مقهى «إيرث» في أبحر الجنوبية
أقصد هل هم يوفروا المكان، وأنت تجي تجهزه وتشغله؟
احنا كانوا يوفروا المكان، وبعدين نجيب التَّصميم
هم ينفذوا التَّصميم؟
وينفذوا التَّصميم
وبعدين يأخذوا نسبة من إيراداتك
نسبة من الإيرادات
لكن تأخذ الموقع مجاني
نأخذ الموقع، والرُّسوم اللي كنا ندفعها لحقوق الامتياز
كانت تروح مُباشرة إلى أصحاب الامتياز
يعني «زوما» ماخذ رسُوم، هذه أخذها «زوما»
«كويا» ماخذ رسُوم، أخذها «كويا»
«نصرت» ماخذ رسُوم، أخذها «نصرت»
هل ربحت في هذا الموسم؟
في المٌجمل، إي ربحت
ربحت في الموسم؟
إي ربحت
وما تكررت لأن نموذج العمل عند المواسم تغيَّر؟
بالضبط يعني مثلًا مقهى «إيرث» لأنه فاتح ما كان في رسوم له
أعطيك إياه، دائمًا هي معادلة
إي
بشكل عام رَبحان، مقهى «إيرث» خسرت
«زوما» ربحت فيه و«كويا» ربحت فيه
«نصرت» و «ساسي» ربحت فيهم، و«إيرث» خسرت
لكن المجمل ربحان
حسنًا
فتنظر لها كذا، هي والأعمال هي عمليات
واليوم أصحاب المطاعم خَلال فترة الموسم اللِّي يصير فيها نزول
أيش أهم الدروس اللي تعطيهم إياها؟
هل روح شارك في الموسم وللا لا؟
خلي إجازات موظفينك في فترة الموسم لأن في هبوط 30%
الآن نحن أكملنا ثلاثة مواسم سياحية تقريبًا
ثلاث سنوات متتالية مواسم سياحيَّة
صحيح
من واقع خبرتكم
أيش هو أفضل تعامل للمستثمرين في هذا هذا القطاع مع هذه الفترة؟
فترة الموسم؟
فترة الموسم
أن أقول لأحد روح شارك في الموسم
هل عندك المقدرة الإدارية والتشغيلية أنك تشارك؟ لأنك لازم توظف
وللا راح تستخدم أحد من الفريق اللي عندك؟
هذا يحدد النُّقطة هذه، كل شركة وشركة يختلف
إن كان فقط راح توظِّف للموسم،
فمعناته أنت بتوظف مؤقت فبالتالي أنت لازم يجيك دعم
أنت لازم تطلب دعم
لأنه أنا أفكر فيها، إذا أنت بتوظف على حسابك
فقط لثلاثة شهور لافتتاح مؤقت، بغض النظر، هو وين
أكيد غير مجدي اقتصاديًّا
لأنك أنت قاعد توظف فقط لثلاثة شهور
ما مداك تحط هيكل وتحط نفقات رأس ماليَّة وتصرف
وتدخل حق ثلاثة شهور
طيب، هذا فيه منه رواتب
ترى الهوامش إذا نجحت وكل شيء تمام
الهوامش ما تتعدى 5% أو 10%
يا ساتر!
هذا اليوم هَامِش ربحكم في القطاع؟
وين الفترة الذهبية في 2014 و2015؟
لا، كان الهَامِش 20% في الفترة الذهبية
أكثر شوي
إلى 25%، 24% تَرا ما تتعدَّاها الهوامش، ما عمره تعدَّتها
بس النَّاس تعتقد أن تشوف الزَّحمة
ما تربط تكلفة الموظفين وتكلفة التَّجهيز وتكلفة الإيجار وتكلفة الأكل
أنت تأكل أكل تدفع قيمة الشَّخص مثلًا 400 أو 350 أو 300 ريال
طيب في تكلفة الأكل هو مو بـ 300 مربح
فبالتالي ما هو موجود
فإذا أنت بتشارك فيه كمؤقَّت، أنا ما أنصح
إذا ما كان جاي فيه ترتيب معين يغطي لك بس لو طلعت منها متعادل
أنت ممكن تستفيد بالتَّسويق، تستفيد هذا
خسائر بسيطة تتحملها من أجل العلامة وإلى آخره
في كلام كثير على موضوع المقارنة بين أسعار الرِّياض والسعوديَّة
وأسعار الخليج والعالم
كل هذه العلامات التجارية اللي أنتُم اليوم مسؤولين عنها
أسعارها أغلى من أسعارها في مكان المنشأ
وأسعارها أغلى من أسعارها في الخليج
ففي ناس كثير أرسلوا مقارنات لأسعار «شكيتي» في الخُبر مع أسعار...
أَنتُم عندكم في الخبر صح؟
نحن عندنا
أسعار «شكيتي» في الخبر مع أسعار «شكيتي» في البحرين
اللي هو يبعد عنه ساعة وحدة
صحيح
البحرين أرخص
ناس يقارنون بين مقهى «إيرث» الرِّياض ومقهى «إيرث» دُبي
وكلها أنتُم تملكونها
واحنا نملكها
تبيعون في دبي أرخص وفي السعوديَّة أغلى
قاعدين تستعلون السعوديين، وللا أيش الفكرة؟
لا والله بالعكس
وليش هذا التفاوت؟
ليش دائمًا الأسعار عندنا أغلى؟
أنت أول شيء عندك سعر السُّوق
يحددها صال عمرك، تكلفة الطَّعام والخدمات اللوجستية
واصلة عندنا السعوديَّة أغلى
شلون؟ مو نفس المورد والمصدر؟
إي، بس شركات التَّخليص الجمركي
احنا ما نخلص بنفسنا، احنا نعطي لشركات
فأنت الموردين اللي تتعامل معهم والمخلص الجمركي وإلى آخره
إلى ما يوصلك المنتج إلى مطعمك
تكلفة وصوله إلى مطعمك أو مقرَّك أو مطبخك أعلى من التَّكلفة في مكان ثاني
ليش؟ رسُوم حكومية ولا وفرة خدمات؟
العمليَّة تطول شوي، فبالتالي أنت كل يوم تطول فيه
هو تكلفة على المُورِّد، شركة الخدمات اللُّوجستيَّة
فبالتالي التَّكلفة مرتفعة، هذا واحد
الشيء الثاني أنت...
هذا أول بند أنه تكلفة التَّخليص الجمركي ومدَّة التخليص في السعوديَّة
أكثر من الخليج، رقم واحد
رقم اثنين؟
رقم اثنين، تكلفة...، أنت لمَّا تسوِّي سياسة التَّسعير
أنت تبني سياسة التَّسعير، ليش؟
أنت تبني أنه تكلفة، عادةً عالميًّا تكلُفة الطَّعام تتراوح تقريبًا 25%
من التَّكلفة الإجمالية، هذا واحد
تكلفة الأكل نفسها المواد
أيه، هذه المعادلة عالميًّا، سياسة التَّسعير
فوائد النُّمو عندك تكون، طال عمرك، من 75% إلى 80%
في مجال المطعام الفاخرة
أنا ما أعرف في «مطاعم الوجبات السريعة» (كيو إس آر) كم
فأنت تتكلم 75% إلى 80%
فعشان تحقق المحدَّدات هذه فيجب أنك تبني سياسة تسعيرك
مبنية على الشيء هذا
احنا تكلفة الموظفين عندنا عالميًّا في المطاعم الرَّاقية
تتراوح من 26% إلى 28% من إجمالي تكلفة التَّشغيل
احنا عندنا ترتفع إلى 40%
فعالميًّا تكلفة العمالة من إجمالي تكاليف...
تكلفة التَّشغيل وتكلفة المواد الغذائيَّة الأولية أعلى
فأنت تربطها حسب المكان اللي أنت موجود فيه
ففي السعوديَّة تكلفة العمالة أعلى؟
بالضبط، تكلفة العمالة إلى 40% توصل
من 35% إلى 40%
كم في فرعكم، في دبي؟
فرعنا في دبي العمالة
العمالة كم يمثلون في المئة من تكاليفكم؟
25% تقريبًا إلى 28%
وفي السعوديَّة 40% ليش؟
أنا متكفل بسكنهم، وأنا متكفل بمواصلاتهم
أنا متكفل بإدارة سكنهم، وأنا متكفل بإدارة مواصلاتهم
أنا عندي إدارة في الإدارة العامَّة
في دبي أنت ما تسكنهم وما تنقلهم ؟
لا، ما لي علاقة
شلون؟
أنا موظف يجيني يداوم السَّاعة كذا في المطعم يِحضر
ليش ما تطبق النِّظام هنا؟
ما عندي، ما أقدر
هنا في تنظيم للسكن، ما يقدر هو يروح يستأجر، لازم أنا أستأجر له
التَّكلفة ارتفعت
أنا في يوم من الأيام...
ما في نقل عام هنا، يمكن هناك المترو
المترو هو اللي يقوم وهو يسكن
ولا أنا أعرف، ولا لي علاقة وين يسكن
هنا لا، لي علاقة وين أسكنه
والبلدية تفتش والمخالفة تيجي على الشَّركة
والشَّركة هي اللي تدفع المُخالفة
مو الموظف اللِّي يدفع المخالفة
أنا مسؤول عن هذا كله
فهذا كله ما هو ببلاش، هذا كله يترتب عليه تكاليف
تكاليف إدارتها، أنا فيصل ما راح أقدر أدير كل شيء
اليوم عندنا ثلاثين فرع مطعم، يالله أدير
فتخيل أني أدير سكن، ما أقدر فلازم تعين ناس
النَّاس هذول اللي تتعينهم مو شخص واحد
طيب لو شخص طلع إجازة؟
هي مجموعة أشخاص، وإدارة كاملة اسمها إدارة تصريف شؤون
إدارة تصريف الشؤون تدير 200 - 1800 موظف
سكنهم وأكلهم وشربهم وموصلاتهم
كم يكلفك السرير؟
أَوَّل السرير في السَّكن المشترك؟
إي
لمَّا بدأنا «نزومي» ثمانية ريال
للسرير؟
للسرير
اليوم؟
كانوا ساكنين قريب إلى درجة اللي يبغى يجي بسيَّارة يجي
أو اللي يبغى يجي برجوله يجي
بعدين صار في تنظيم
تنظيم اللي هي أماكن محددة يسكنونها العمالة، غيرها ممنوع
غيرها ممنوع، ارتفع اليوم إلى ثلاثة وعشرين ريال
ثلاثة وعشرين ريال؟
من ثمانية إلى ثلاثة وعشرين ريال غير تكلفة المواصلات
والوقت اللي يقضيه في الباص في المواصلات يدخل من وقت العمل
لأن هو....
طبعًا
من طلعته من باب السكن
طلعته من باب السكن
هو بدأ عمل؟
هو بدأ عمل
فهذه التكاليف لما تيجي تحسب
سألتني كيف كنت تسوي أرباح وصرت تسوي
أحسب هي ترى واحد زائد واحد يساوي اثنين
فيجب أنك تنظر إلى التَّكاليف كاملة مكملة، ما أنظر إلى عامل واحد
هي مجموعة عوامل مركَّبة مع بعض
فاحنا قلنا...
زمان ما كان في مقابل مالي
مقابل مالي، حسنًا
اليوم في عندك مقابل مالي
الشَّخص الأجنبي يكلفك 9600 ريال في السَّنة
لو عندك 1000 شخص هذا 9 مليون و600
طيب ربحك كله مو 9 مليون و 600
أنت عندك 2000...
2000 بس فيه منهم سعوديين، الإجمالي...
كم نسبة السَّعودة عندك؟
في المكتب الرَّئيسي؟
في الكُل
في المكتب الرَّئيسي
الـ 1800 هذول كم منهم سعوديين؟
60% السَّعودة في في المكتب الرَّئيسي
في خارج في المكتب الرَّئيسي أنت لازم تحافظ على نسبة السَّعودة
اللي هي تقريبًا 30% عشان تجلس على الأخضر
بس الآن، إن شاء الله فيه الحمد لله، مبادرات كثيرة جالسين نشتغل عليها
راح نسولف فيها في الأخير
بس أنا لسَّه أبغى أفهم فروقات بيئة العمل بيننا وبين دول خليج
اللي قاعدة تقدم نفس العلامات التجارية
في كثير من الحالات بتجربة أحسن وسعر أرخص، وهذا يستَفز النَّاس
أنه أنا آكل في نفس العلامة التجارية في دبي أو البحرين
بسعر أرخص وتجربة أحسن
صح، بشكل عام، أنت كذا قل لي تجربة أحسن وأنا أرجع
لأنه احنا في الشَّركة عندنا أهم شيء
من غيرتنا أنه ما أرضى واحد زائر من برَّة
يقول أنا جربت «كويا» على سبيل المثال في الرِّياض
وجرَّبت «كويا» في خارج السعوديَّة في أي فرع
ويقول هذاك أحس، أغار
بس هذا الواقع، ليش؟
حرام عليك، بس «كويا»
ما أعرف «كويا» صراحةً بس أقصد إجمالًا
نشتغل
إجمالًا في هذه...
إجمالًا في طيب...
يستثنى «ميازو» لأنه شهادة حق
من 2014 أزور هذا المكان، ومستوى الخدمة محافظين عليه بطريقة ملفتة
لدرجة النَّاس يبغون يعرفون
أيش السر؟ لو تقدر تشاركنا دروس من حفاظكم على التَّجربة
علامات تجارية ثانية مثلًا «شكيتي» دائمًا عندي معاناة
كل مرة أجي يصير لي موقف سيء مع الخدمة
الخدمة مرَّة سيِّئة، مو عادية، الخدمة سيئة
مع أنه، ما شاء الله، مليان وربحانين
ممكن علشان كِذا ما أَنتُم مهتمين بالخدمة
لا والله
لأنه ربحانين ومليان المطعم
بس مو لحالي، فيه كذا شخص يتكلمون على أن الخدمة ما هي مرضية
هذه ملاحظة ممتازة عشان أني أروح أشوف
ولما دخلت على تقييمكم لقيته أنه هو 3.9
أيه
تحت الأربعة، بينما «ميازو» تتكلم على 4.2
صحيح
حتى النَّاس قاعدة تعكس هذا...
فلو راح أتكلم على عنصر جودة الخدمة
نعم
والتذبذب اللي فيه
أيش أكثر الأشياء اللي تُأثر عليكم بحيث إنكم ما تقدرون تضبطون الجودة؟
وأيش الدرًّوس اللي تقدر تهديها للناس
من واقع تجربتكم في «ميازو» كمطعم محافظ على الجودة؟
صحيح
طال عمرك، في عندنا عدِّة عوامل
برَّة في أوربا، على سبيل المثال، تسافر وتشوف
تقدر عندك التَّوظيف المَرن
أنت لما توظف أحد توظف في الصِّيف حسب احتياجك
أنا الآن عندي موسم في السعوديَّة
زي ما تفضلت أنت في البداية، الشِّتاء هو موسمنا
هذا جوَّنا وطلعاتنا وروحاتنا، الجو يساعدنا على الخُروج
طب أبغى أوظِّف في الشِّتاء لأني أعرف أن الطلب على المطاعم
والإقبال يزيد في الشِّتاء
ما أقدر، أنا العقود اللي أوقعها أقل شيء سنة أو سنتين
ما أقدر، وبعدين يجيني رَمضان
موت، ما في أحد في المطاعم
لأن النَّاس تتجمع في البيوت وتفطر في البيوت
وإذا بتطلع تروح إلى الخيم الرَّمضانية، وأنا منهم
مو أنا جالس إنِّي هذا...، أنا منهم
نتجمع في البيوت ونفطر وهذه عاداتنا
أول عائق أنَّ طبيعة العقود أنها كلها عقود غير مَرنة
سنة، وأَنت ملزم فيها
طيب، وهذا ما يخدمني أنا أرتبط فيه وأجلس وأسَكِّنه وأرتبط بسكنه
فتكلفه توظيفة عشان أستفيد من الموسم
شهرين أو ثلاثة موسم الشِّتاء
أستفيد من موسم الشِّتاء وأزيد عدد موظفيني
عشان يقدروا يخدموا بالطريقة الصحيحة
ما تساعدني العقود
لأنه كمان حط نفسك مكاننا لازم أنظر للعملية التِّجارية
من ناحية شويَّة بس عشان الشَّركة مو تكمل
وليس طمعًا عشان أربح، أنا قاعد أخسر
فما في طمع، بس أبغى أكمِّل
عشان تكمل يجب أنك...
فهذا أول عائق، غيره؟
هذا واحد، العائق الثاني، طال عمرك
أنك تأخذ جودة عالية من الموظفين ترى مو سهل عندنا في السعوديَّة
والسَّبب أنك تدفع المبالغ في أنك تجيب أوربيين، على سبيل المثال
نحن ما نقول أوربيين، نقول موظفين ذو خبرة
موظفين ذووا خبرة عالية، وعدد كبير احنا نجيب
بس ما نجيب كل المطعم بتجربة عالية
لأنه راح تكون التَّكاليف جدًّا عالية
لدرجة أنه بجميع أحوالها، لو المطعم مليان صبح وليل، غير مجدية
ليش؟ لا تنسى نقطة مهمة
احنا عندنا المطاعم الرَّاقية برة تعتمد كثير على المشروبات الكحولية
لأن الهوامش وربحهم هو مو في الأكل
الأكل هي اللي يجيب...
جرَّة رجل
جرَّة رجل، احنا لا، احنا نعتمد على الأكل
هو اعتماده مُختلف تمامًا
أعطيك مثال، في دبي كم تتوقع المطاعم الرَّاقية المعادلة
تمثل بيع الكحول فيها مقارنة بالأكل؟
كم؟
55% مقابل 45% للكحول
شلون؟
مبيعاتهم
إيوة %55 من مبيعات المطاعم الرَّاقية كحول؟
كحول، و45% أكل
أيش التَّكلفة للكحول؟
كتَّكلُفة نتكلم، هل في طاهي؟ ما في طاهي
أنت عندك مخزون
جَرد، ولمَّا يجي يقيِّمها المُحاسب تزيد ما تنقص
المخاطرة، بالنسبة لهم، أنا الحين أتكلم كنموذج
ما أتكلم كشريعة ودين
صح
فما في، المخزون يزيد
المخزون إي
المخزون تزيد قيمته
زي اللي عنده سيجارة اللي لو مشتريها من ثلاث سنوات، اليوم زاد قيمته
في الأكل لا، أنت مخزونك بالعكس تُضر لأن مخزونك له صلاحيَّة
فلازم تستهلكه
طيب كم يمثل الكحول من ربحيَة القطاع؟
«كويا» دبي لا تروح بعيد 55% كحول و45% أكل
كإيرادات؟
كإيرادات
طيب كربحية؟
كربحية الكحول 30% الحد الأدنى، صَافي
أنا أقول لك لازم تأخذ هذا بالاعتبار
أنت سألتني ليش الأسعار عندنا...
هو ينزل الأكل عشان يجيبك، جرَّة رجل
ربحه من الكحول
إي ربحه من الكحول
أنا أرفع سعري، فالمقارنة غير عادلة
فاللي قادر يجيب هذا المستوى من مقدمي الخدمة قادر يتحمل تكلفتهم
لأنه عنده بند إضافي ما هو موجود عندك اللي هو الكحول
طبعًا، فهو قادر، بالعكس هو يبغى يجيب أكثر
ويبغى يتعامل أكثر، وإلى آخره
ثاني شيء التَّكلفة عنده...
اليوم أنا لو بجيب نادل إيطالي يكلفني في الشهر 10 آلاف ريال
تعرف في دبي كم يدفع؟
كم؟
5 آلاف ريال
ليش؟
يستلم راتب
أنا يكلفني 10 لأنه يكلفني أني إذا ما وفرت له سكن أعطيه بدل سكن
أشياء وبدالات كثيرة
هناك في دبي يقول له: تبغى تشتغل أو ما تبغى تشتغل؟
أنت روح دبِّر عمرك
أعطيك مثال بسيط، في بعض الموظفين...
هذه ملفتة أنت تتكلم على 100% زيادة؟
%100 زيادة أنا أعطيك مثال حَي
«كويا» الرِّياض عندنا في بعض الموظفين
«كويا» دبي طلبوهم أنَّهم يتحولوا عندهم
قلنا حسنًا، ما عندنا مانع خلاص يتحولوا ويروحوا تمامًا
كم يستلموا عندكم؟
هذا اللي يستلم هذا الرواتب اللي عندنا
قال: لا، شكرًا خلوهم عندكم
أنت راح تخرب الرواتب اللي عندنا احنا ترى يستلم نُص المَبلغ
بس الزيادة هذه إذا هي رسوم حكومية فهي ما تنعكس على الرَّاتب
لا، ما تنعكس على الرَّاتب
أنا أتكلم معاك يكلِّفنا، التَّكلفة
إي
التَّكلفة تشمل، احنا اللي ندفع عنَّه
التَّكلفة الإجماليَّة يكلفنا
يعني مثلًا اللي هو يستلمه في جيبه 8 آلاف ريال
واحنا تكلفته الإجماليَّة طالعه علينا 10 آلاف ريال
في دبي راح يأخذ 4 آلاف؟
في دبي راح يأخذ 4 آلاف ونص
هذا أنا أقول لك الأمريكيين الَّلاتنيين، على سبيل المثال
على طاري الرَّواتب، كثير أسئلة جتنا
من أنكم توظفون السعوديين، بنفس المهمة بس أن الرَّواتب أقل
ليش؟
هذه شكاوي بعض السعوديين اللي يشتغلوا معكم
يقول أنا نفس المهمة اللي زميلي الأشقر أبو عيون زرقاء يسويها
سلَّم رواتبه غير سلَّم رواتبي، ويأخذ رواتب عالية جدًّا
أنا أؤدي نفس المهمة، وراتبي أقل
احنا عندنا سلم موحَّد يمكن هو ما عنده خبر
إذا كان المُشغلين...
طبعًا أنا أتكلم بشكل عام ما أتكلم سعوديين
مُشغلين هذا سلم رواتبهم، نُدل هذا سلم رواتبهم
رئيس النُّدل هذا سلم رواتبهم، مدير طابق هذا سلم
ما فيه أي تقسيم في الجنسيَّة؟
وين يفرق؟
أيوة
يا سلام، كل الأجانب يشتغلون عندنا ستة أيام
أصلًا لو صارت خمسة أيام كان مقفل من بكرة
أقول لك ما فيه خلاص غير مجدية أبدًا تصير، ستَّة أيَّام
السعوديين عقودهم خمسة أيام
الآن أيش صرنا نسوي؟
نعرض بغض النَّظر سعودي أو غير سعودي
أي واحد خمسة أيام نعرض عليه
أن ترى راح نروح لستَّة أيَّام ويجيك زيادة بسيطة
90% قبلوا الجادِّين، قالوا موافقين نشتغل ستة أيام، ونأخذ الزِّيادة
اللي ما وافق، قلنا له: على وقت تجديد العقد خلاص ما عندنا
خلاص السِّيَاسة وحدة
السياسة وحدة، ستة أيَّام وراح تجيك زيادة
لأن أنت كمان تبغى تنظر إلى الفعاليَّة
أنا قلت لك: الآن لمَّا أنت تكون خسران في سنين متتالية وراء بعض
واجب عليك وحق عليك أنك تنظر، كيف تخفِّض خسائرك؟
وتكون فعَّال عشان تقدر تكمل وتنجو
لأن احنا نعتبر نفسنا جزء من السِّياحة
وجزء من واجهة السِّياحة ومن جودة الحياة
فواجب علينا أن نستمر وبصورة حسنة
طيب خلينا نسوي أبو عبد الله، آسف، تكبير
ونشوف المشهد من بعيد كصورة كبيرة
صحيح
أَنتُم اليوم كم علامة تجارية عندكم؟
عندنا، يا طويل العمر، إحدى عشر علامة تجارية
إحدى عشر علامة تجارية، كم فرع؟
الإجمالي ثلاثين فرع
ثلاثين فرع، كم مدينة؟
الرياض وجِدة والشرقية والعُلا ودُبي
نشتغل في خمس مدن
خمس مدن، كم موظف؟ قلت لي 1800
1900 تقريبًا
1900، في عدَّة أسئلة لكم كمجموعة
بما أنكم عندكم هذه التَّجربة
أولَّها سؤال، وين أفتح بأي مدينة؟
ليش في إهمال للخبر؟
كثير من أهالي الشَّرقية يقولون...
كثير مستثمرين يعزفون عن الاستثمار في الخبر
مع أن فيها قوَّة شِرائية، وفيها تعداد سكاني جيد
بس المستثمرين يتحاشونها
ليش كل شيء في الرِّياض؟
أعطيك مثال، وبكل صدق وأمانة
عندنا «تشكيتي» في الرِّياض وفي جدة وفي الخبر
الثلاثة «تشكيتي» في الرِّياض متوسِّط الفاتورة...
متوسط الفاتورة
متوسط الفاتورة 190 ريال
في «تشكيتي» أنا أعطيك هذه اعتبارًا من أمس
حلو
في جدة أقل 170 ريال، وفي الخبر 110 ريال
طيب أنا...
أرامكو معودتهم يمسكون الدَّراهم شكلهم
لأن هم كمتوسط دخل يعتبرون من الأعلى
عالي، أعلى شيء عندهم «أرامكو»
أكبر شركة في العالم، وليس في السعوديَّة، في العالم
وما شاء الله تبارك الله، يوجد عندهم بيوت تجارية كبيرة جدًّا
لكن احنا نتكلم كسلوك، يسموه سلوك الصَّرف
190 و110
حسنًا
فهذا هو السبب المُباشر والصَّريح
أنا ما توفِّي معاي
أن مُجتمع الشَّرقية ما هو مجتمع يصرف
عندي تكلفة أعلى، أنا أطلع لهم يوميًّا سيارة من الرِّياض
من «سانيور ساسي»
لأن عندنا احنا المطعم الوحيد اللي نسويه طازج، كل الموزاريلا حقَّتنا
اللي تشوفها وكل أنواع الجبنة
تطلع كل يوم من غُرفة الموزاريلا حقَّتنا، معلومة ما أحد يعرفها
المطعم الوحيد
يمكن في دبي ما في مطعم ثاني يسوي موزاريلَّا طازجة
احنا بس نستورد حليب الثَّور، وحليب البقر من إيطاليا
والجبنة تطلع عندنا طازجة يوميًّا
اللي تتقدم اللي تشوفها في المطاعم عندنا مدتها ساعتين
ما شاء الله
نرسل سيارة يوميًّا تطلع توصل الجبنة إلى...
فهذا جواب على سؤال، ليش الإحجام عن الخبر والشَّرقيَّة؟
مو إحجامً، ما في إحجام
بس عدم توسّع
ليش أفتح في الرياض أولًا
وثاني شيء، المطاعم تحتاج إشراف يومي
إشراف يومي، ما تقدر
مثل الطفل الصِّغير تقدر يكون عندك طفل صغير وتهمله؟ ما تقدر
والمطعم ما عمره راح يكبر، راح يضل دائمًا طفل صغير
اليوم اللي تهمله، اعرف أن اليوم مستواه ينزل
أي، ومقارنة الرِّياض ودبي؟
الإقبال في «إيرث» الرِّياض أعلى
الرِّياض أعلى
إقبال
إي
الرِّبحية؟
الرِّبحية في الرِّياض أفضل من دبي
الرِّياض يربح أكثر من دبي
إي، كربحية
حسنًا
دبي، الحمد لله، مسوي كويس ما أقولك
مو مسوي ممتاز، لا مسوي كويس يغطي تكاليفه في الرِّبحية
السَّنة هذه بدأ الرِّبحية
صار فيه تفعيل من المالك الموجود لأنه في «سيتي ووك 2»
فصار فيه ضغط مع صاحب الملك
نزَّل لنا الإيجارات، فبالتالي خفف من خسائري
فابدأ يصير في إيجابية، وكفاءة في التَّشغيل
كملت خمس سنين في دبي
تونا ما أقلك نزَلت الإجارات، توَّنا خلَّصنا
العقد الأول كان خمس سنوات، فكنت مخنوق ماني قادر أنزِّل
فلما جاء وقت التَّجديد نزلت الإيجارات أو كنت بطلع
واحد من الاثنين، فصار فيه كفاءة
بس اليوم المستثمر اللي يبغى يبدأ
تنصحه يبدأ من وين؟
احنا ما زلنا، وكل هذه الحلقة تتكلم على الشريحة حقَّت مطاعمكم
المطاعم الرَّاقية أو فوق الغير رسمية
أي مدينة يبدأ فيها تنصحه؟
حسب هو وين؟ إذا هو كان في المدينة المنورة
يجب أن يكون جنب مطعمه، ما يقدر يبدأ...
العبرة في أنك تكون جنب مطعمك
جنب مطعمك، احنا بدأنا في الرِّياض لأن احنا في الرِّياض موجودين
لو يمكن كنا موجودين في جدة أو في الشرقية
ترى كانت المعادلة مختلفة
خلنا نفترض أن أنت في الرِّياض
أيش الخطوة التَّالية للتوسع، وين أروح؟
باقي مناطق السعودية
ما تروح برة السعوديَّة؟
لا
الخليج وكذا؟
أنا أحب أشتغل في المكان اللي أنا أعرفه
والمطاعم تعتمد كثير على أن أنت تعرف المكان
والدليل على كذا كل العلامات العالميَّة
ما يقدر هو ياخذ قرار يستثمر لأنه مو عايش في البلد
فبالتالي صعب عليه
فنفس الشيء أنت لما تطلع إلى بلد خارجي
في مخاطرة إذا ما معاك شريك محلِّي
أيش المدينة الثَِّانية بعد الرِّياض للي عنده مطعم؟
ولا يمسك مطعمه ولا يتوسع؟
اللي عنده مطعم؟
إي، اللي عنده مطعم في الرِّياض
ناجح؟
ناجح، أيش الخطوة الثَّانية؟
لا، إذا ناجح يتوسَّع، الحمد لله
إي وين، أيش المدينة الثَّانية؟
الشَّرقيَّة فيها خير، وجدة فيها خير وفي مُدن أُخرى
المنطقة الجنوبيَّة، حسب الدِّراسات بس مو على المطاعم الرَّاقية
لأن ما في مطاعم رَّاقية، بس حسب الدِّراسات
أقوى قوَّة شرائيَّة في المنطقة الجنوبية
بعد الرِّياض وجدة؟
أبها
لا، أقوى قوَّة شرائيَّة في السعوديَّة في الأكل والشرب
أقوى من الرِّياض؟
أقوى من الرِّياض
كيف؟
في القوَّة الشرائيَّة، الصَّرف لأنه هو طبع
ففيه صَرف، يعني راحوا أربعة يطلبون حق ستة، عادات وتقاليد
في أبها
بس ما فتحتوا ولا شيء في أبها أنتم؟
لسَّه ما فتحنا لأنه الخدمات اللوجستيَّة
ترى، ما شاء الله، المملكة العربية السُّعودية كبيرة
إي
فأنت لما تتكلم تسافر من جدة للرياض بالسيَّارة
عشر ساعات أو بالشَّاحنة إثنى عشر ساعة، وبالطيارة ساعة ونص
إي
مع المطارات رايح جاي
فأنت، ما شاء الله تبارك الله، التَّنقل بين المدن في السُّعوديَّة كبيرة
فلوجستيًّا صحيح هي داخل السُّعوديَّة
بس بعيدة، ما شاء الله تبارك الله
فأبها هي قريبة وبعيدة
هي داخل السُّعوديَّة لكنها برضو...
فلازم تفكر في الخدمات اللوجستيَّة، ولازم تفكر في الإشراف
لازم تفكر في الزِِّيارات الإشرافيَّة، وإلى آخره هذه الأشياء
بس بالتأكيد التَّوسع داخل السعوديَّة هذه خطوة أولى
قبلَما أنِّي أفكر أني أتوسَّع خارج السعوديَّة
في عندك السِّياحة الدينيَّة، مكة المكرمة والمدينة المنورة
في تعطش ولا ما في تعطش؟
في ملايين المعتمرين والزُّوار والحجاج اللي ييجوا
بس ما فتحتو ولا فرع أنتُم؟
راح نفتح، إن شاء الله
وين؟
هذه خطتنا التَوسعية
الحين المنافسين يجوا
خلينا نكشف أوراقكم، أيش المدن القادمة؟
إن شاء الله بإذن الله، المدينة المنورة ومكة المكرمة
راح تكون من خطواتنا الجايَّة
مو شرط مطاعم الرَّاقية
نركب الشيء بما....لكنه الغير رسمي
الغير رسمي، اللي هو الشيء من ضمن المجموعة الحاليَّة
وللا علامات تجارية جديدة؟
لا، من ضمن المجموعة الحاليَّة
مثل أيش؟
ممكن يكون مقهى «إيرث»
مقهى «إيرث»
مقهى «إيرث» تتوسع في المدينة المنورة، وتتوسع في مكة المكرمة
بالعكس أنا أشوف أن هذه هي القادم
توسُّعكم القادم، هل هو بنفس النموذج السابق
أنك تأخذ علامات تجارية عالمية كحق امتياز؟
ولا راح تبدأ تشتغل على علاماتك التجارية؟
احنا بدأنا نشتغل، راح يكون هجين بين هذه وبين هذه
يعني لسَّه مُقتنع أنت بجدوى أخذ علامات تجاريَّة عالميَّة؟
آخذ علامات إذا أنا ما أقدر أسوِّي زيَّها، هذا واحد
إذا الاسم جدًّا كبير وقوي
ويضيف قيمة ويعطينا المعرفة، احنا نتعلم
لمَّا نأخذ حق امتياز ترى نتعلم، ويضيف لنا
إذا ما شفنا أن الاسم هذه ممكن يضيف لنا من معرفة عملية، ومحفظة إستثماريّة
ومن اسم، لا مو بس عشان الاسم، بس لازم يعطينا معرفة
فالشَّركة اللي نبغى نأخذ منها
نبغى نأخذ من شركة فعلًا تكمِّلنا، وتضيف لنا شيء
إذا ما فيها إضافة معرفة
احنا الحمد لله، الآن بقدرتنا أن نصدر معرفة
مو بس أن نستورد معرفة
فسوينا «ميازو» كان أول خطوة
والحمد لله، ترا في هذيك الأيام
لما نغير من «ميازو» إلى «نزومي» كثير ناس...
من «نزومي» إلى «ميازو» قصدك
من «نزومي» إلى «ميازو» كثير ناس قالوا أنتُم متأكدين؟
حتى داخل الشَّركة، أنتُم متأكدين؟
زملائي وأخواني في العمل، قالوا متأكد؟
قلنا، إن شاء الله بإذن الله
خليك واثق، والحمد لله، جاءتنا تغذية راجعة جدًّا قوية وإيجابية
حتى لدرجة الناس تقول هذا «نزومي بلس»
فعلًا، التجربة، ما شاء الله، الهويَّة ناجحة
فالحمد لله، هذا واحد
سوّينا «كايزو» في الطلبات الخارجية
اللي هو زمان كان اسمه «نوزومي توكو» تغير إلى «كايزو»
وجدًّا عليه إقبال كويس وبأسعار أرخص
نفس المكونات حقّت «ميازو»
ونفس المواد الخام فما فيها كلام بس تكلفة التَّشغيل أرخص
سوِّينا «روباتا» في الداير الشَّمالي في حطِّين
في بيكانوبي، الحمد لله تبارك الله، هذه علامتنا الخاصَّة
قائمة الطعام من الصِّفر احنا اللي سوِّيناها وطورناها
هذه كلها تحت «ميازو فاميلي»
«روباتا» و«كايزو» تحت «ميازو»
الآن إن شاء الله نهاية الشَّهر
المطعم الإيطالي اللي احنا سوِّيناه اسمه «آجو»
احنا سوينا العلامة التجارية
جلسنا نتشتغل عليه سنة تقريبًا العلامة التجارية لمطعمنا الخاص
اللي بيدخل القطاع هذا أنت تنصحه يبدأ بحق امتياز ولا...؟
عنده معرفة وللا لا؟
لا، ما عنده
أنا أنصحه بحق الامتياز، إذا ما عنده معرفة
بس لمَّا يجيب حق الامتياز يحاول يتعلم المعرفة
مو بس يجيب حق إمتياز، ويكون هو الذي راكب في الكرسي الخلفي
لا، حرام، حاول تركب في الكرسي اللي جنب السَّواق
وتشوف السَّواق شلون يسوق
في ملاحظة على طريقة عملكم بشكل عام النَّاس
يقولون أن أنتم تجيبون علامات هي في بلدها «مطاعم عادية» أو «مطاعم عادية سريعة»
وتجون هنا تفخمونها مرَّة، وتصير «مطاعم فاخرة»
بأسعار أعلى وبتجربة مختلفة عن الأساس
هل تتفق مع هذه الملاحظة؟
والله قد يكون تجربة مقهى «إيرث» أن فخمنا المكان
بس الروح هي نفسها ما تغيَّرت لكن ديكور المكان صحيح، تغيَّر وأضفنا
وجاءتنا تعليقات كثير إيجابية
أن أنتم رفعتم من مستوى مقهى «إيرث»
لدرجة أن الآن صارت الشَّركة الأم برَّة تبغى تتعامل مع «ريتشارد»
بدأت تتعامل مع «ريتشارد» مباشرةً
حبوا التَّحسينات اللي أنتُم...
التَّحسينات اللي احنا عملناها
هذا شيء يعزز لنا أن احنا صرنا نعطي التغيير
وليش كل مطاعمكم تدور في فلك إيطالي، ياباني؟
ما راحتوا إيراني، ما راحتوا هندي، ما راحتوا لمطابخ أخرى؟
هذه واحدة من المخطَّطات
أيش المطابخ اللي ناويين تدخلونها؟
أو اللي أنت شايف السُّوق ما تشبَّع منها؟
ما تشبَّع منها، في عندك ثلاثة: الأكل الإيراني كمطبخ، من حيث الطعم ونحبه
لأن فيه رز وفيه لحوم
والنَّاس يحبونه غريب أن ما في شيء موجود في السُّوق
الأكل الهندي، النَّاس تحبه
جدًّا
جدًّا، والمغربي
المغربي صحيح
فهذه الثلاثة أَنتُم مهتمين فيها
مهتمين فيها وغير موجودة بعدد كافي
مين من التَّجارب المحليَّة اللي أنت تعتقد أنها تجربة لأحد المنافسين
اللي تستحق الإشادة أو اللي مسوي لكم شويَّة قلق
لأن كأنِّي فهمت إنه صار اليوم فيه زي تحالفات أو تكتلات
فيه «مجموعة شاكر»
أنتم طبعًا جاء وطلع من عندكم، وصرتوا أنتم الإخوان الثلاثة
من أول إي
فأنتُم أخوان الثلاثة تملكون المجموعة
صحيح
ومعاكم الأمير «عبدالله بن نايف» في جزئية «إيرث»
في شركة منفصلة
فيه مجموعات أخرى ماسكة مجموعة علامات
وفي أفراد يشتغلون على علاماتهم الخاصَّة
أيش التَّجربة اللي تقول أنا كمنافس أحترم هذا الشخص
ومر مبسوط باللي قاعد يسويه
وأقول: الله يستر، لا يأكل علينا الجو
أولًا بكل صدق وأمانة، أنا أحترمهم كلهم، والله العظيم
وفي نقطة ثانية
أنا ما أحاول أشغل نفسي بالمنافسة كثير
لأن أخاف أخسر اللي عندي ويصير تركيزي على المنافسة
وأخسر التركيز اللي عندي لأن تحتاج هذا، وهذه تؤثر عليك
لكن أنا على الصعيد الشخصي
أنا في شيء أحبه مرة وأعزِّه، مطعم «إل بي أم»
«إل بي أم» هذا تبع مجموعة الفيصلية صح؟
الخزامى، وأنا صراحة...
والصراحة أنه مميز ومن الأشياء القليلة اللي حافظت...
حتى المطبخ نفسه، أحب الجلسة وأحب الخدمة
وأروح له كثير لأن أحب أن أروحه، وليس أروح عشان أفتش ولا أشوف
لا، أروح أبغى أستمتع، أكون طالع من جو الشُّغل، فأبغى أروحه
ومو بس هذا، أروح لـ«فيا رياض»
أحب مجموعة من المطاعم هناك
ذقت المطعم الهندي اللي هناك؟
أووو «جيمخانا»؟
«جيمخانا»
من ألذ المطاعم الهندية
رهيب صراحةً
من ألذ، «ميشلان ستار» هذا واحد
من ألذ المطاعم الهندية، وأستمتع في روحتي لهناك
ترى الرُّوحة... لأنِّي أحيانًا أنا أفاجئك
لما أروح إلى مطاعم شَّركة «إم إف سي» مطاعمنا في الشَّركة
أحس نفسي رايح شغل، وأنا أبغى أطلع من جَو الشغل
فتجرب مطاعم برَّة المجموعة؟
أطلع أجرب لأنه من الاستقبال إلى المدير إلى الموظفين كلهم يعرفوني
فيصير فيه...فأحيانًا أبغى أروح مكان ما تعرف...
وين المهرب حقك، أكثر مهرب تروح له؟
دائمًا من ضمن المطاعم أكثر مهرب «إل بي أم»
«إل بي أم»
«البجيري» كيف تشوف تجربة...؟
شتوي
أحبه في الشِّتاء، أشيل همه في الصِّيف
لأنه في مَشية وفيه مشية في الصيف
أحبه في الشِّتاء
المعروض واضح أنه ما راح يقل المعروض قاعد يزيد
كل مطور عقاري بالذات المطورين الحكوميين
أو اللي تبع شركات صندوق الاستثمارات العامة
جزء أساسي من معروضهم مطاعم
وأحيانًا يسوون تسهيلات وخصومات خاصَّة
وسعر إيجار مخفض عشان يجيب علامات تجارية عالميَّة
فالواضح أن أكبر مشكلة تعانون منها اليوم اللي هي المعروض الزائد
ليست في طريقها للحل
إلى متى بتخسرون؟ أيش بتسوون؟
أيش الحل لهذا الواقع؟
والله الحل صح
لأنه عليكم وعلى السوق كله يبدو لي، صح؟
لا، كله السُّوق كامل الشَّركات كاملة
وزي ما قلت لك أن فيه مبادرات في المجتمع
أنا أتوقع عشان القطاع هذا يقدر يكمل بشكل عام لازم يجيه دعم
الدعم هذا مثلما تفضلت إلى أن الطلب يتوافق مع العرض المعروض
الطلب جالس يزيد لكن ماخذ وراح يأخذ وقته
والعرض الآن صار كثير والعرض جالس يزيد
ولا هو مهدي، جالس يزيد
فبالتالي هذه راح تأخذ من الحصَّة السُّوقية أكثر وأكثر
لازم يجي دعم عشان القطاع يقدر يكمل لأن ما في حل
ليش مطاعم دبي ما طلبت دعم؟
يعني في مسؤوليين حكوميين يشوفون القطاع الخاص السُّعودي
أدمن الدَّعم وأدمن طلبات...
أبغى أسألك سؤال، لما نروح دبي
خَلنا نسمي أي مطعم مشهور «نصرت» أو «زوما»
المطاعم المشهورة الموجودة في دبي
كم مقيم، وكم سائح جوا إلى المطعم؟
في الأغلبية قد يكونون سياح، صح؟
سياح
إي، احنا هنا عندنا العكس
احنا هنا العكس تمامًا
فأنت كم تقدر الشَّخص هذا...
ترجعه المطعم
ترجعه المطعم كم مرة؟ ما تقدر
فاللي معبي مطاعم دبي سُيَّاح
سُيَّاح
ما هم السُّكان
بينما هنا احنا معتمدين على السُّكان
بالضبط
فما لم تنشط السِّياحة
بعض المطاعم، من غير ما أذكر أسماء، ما يصير، ما يحق لي أن أذكر أسمها
هنا في السعوديَّة، فاضية
في دبي، هي ما تزال اليوم أكبر من أكثر خمس مطاعم إيرادات ما تزال إلى اليوم
ومن أشهر خمس مطاعم، ليش؟
لأنها في الأجندة حقَّت السائح
أني أزور المطعم هذا، معلم سياحي
لكن يمكن أنا وأنت ما رحناه من زمان حتى لما نروح دبي
لكن السائح اللي جاي من برَّة معلم سياحي
أيش نوع الدعم اللي ينتظره القطاع من الحكومة؟
أيش تنتظروا من الحكومة؟
أنا أعطيك مثال بسيط اليوم عندنا
سؤالي لك، هل تعتبر المطاعم الفاخرة وجهة سياحية؟
أعتقد للكثيرين إي، في مجموعة ما يحبون هذا النوع من السياحة
بس في مجموعة كبيرة
سياحتهم قائمة 100% على مواقع المطاعم الرَّاقية
وهل تعتبرها طال عمرك جزء من جودة الحياة وأنها رفاهية في المدينة؟
بوجود مطاعم فاخرة هي جزء من رفاهيَّة الحياة؟
هي مرتبطة حتى في العواصم الكبرى، صحيح
لو جينا قلنا صندوق التَّنمية السِّياحي
من اسمه، صندوق التَّنمية السِّياحي
يدعم ويساعد كلما يتعلق بقطاع تطوير السِّياحة
وإذا جينا قلنا المطاعم الفاخرة جدًّا وجودها مهم
لتطوير ودعم السِّياحة الداخلية والخارجية، الاثنين
فمع الوضع الحالي قد يكون هناك فيه قروض مدعومة
طويلة الأمد بفترة سماحة عشان تمر بالأزمة
تدعم التدفق المالي أن وين المشكلة اللي صايرة أنت عندك؟
هي تدفق النَّقدي، فالتدفق النَّقدي سَالب
لمَّا يكون التدفق النَّقدي أنت خسائرك مستمرة
يجيك رمضان طب أيش نسوي؟
أنت شغَّال اثنا عشر شهر طيب 365 يوم
رمضان موسم ضعيف، والصيف موسم ضعيف، لأن شريحتك تسافر كثير
والصيف في طلعات الغداء ما في أحد، المطاعم فاضية
ليش؟ لأني أنا مع درجة الحرارة العالية أشيل هم إني أطلع من مكتبي
فبعتمد على «جاهز» و«هنقرستيشن» و«ذا شيف» وكل التَّطبيقات
وأطلب، وأنا جالس تحت المكيف
ما راح أشغل سيارتي في الشَّمس وأطلع، وأوقفها تحت الشَّمس
وأرجع مرة ثانية، أدوخ
ففي عوامل كثير ما هِي بيدَّنا ، ولا هو بيد قطاع المطاعم
ولا بيد أحد
هذه عوامل موجودة شهر رمضان، شهر الخير والبركة
الصِّيف النَّاس مسافرة ودرجة الحرارة عالية، والناس مسافرة
طيب أنا كم شهر أشتغل في السَّنة؟
خليني أتخيل أنا رئيس الصندوق التَّنمية السِّياحي
هذا القطاع قاعد يقول أنا عندي رمضان وعندي صيف وحر
هذه باقية للأبد
أنا أقرضتك متى بترجع لي؟
إذا أنتم قطاع تقولوا احنا الإمداد عالي، واحنا قاعدين نخسر
شلون تسدد لي؟ ليش أقرضك؟
خلَّي السوق يفلتر نفسه، خلِّي بعض المطاعم تطلع
ويرجع السوق يصبح بالحجم الطَّبيعي الموافق للطلب
أنا أعطيك مثال، هل حلو لما اسم عالمي يسكر
ويقول أنا فتحت في مدينة الرِّياض
والله ما أراد وتوفقت وقفلت، مو حلوة!
هذه تضر حتى في شكل مباشر وغير مباشر
تضر حتى بالمستثمر الأجنبي اللي جالس يفكر يجي
فأنت في تكلفة مباشرة وغير مباشرة
فلمَّا نتيجي تنظر إلى منافعها المباشرة والغير مباشرة
لا أنا من الأفضل لي أني أجي أقول
لا، أبغى العلامة التِّجارية العالميَّة تكمل
أبغى المطاعم هذه تكمل
لأن أنا أبغى أستقطب زيادة من المستثمرين الأجانب عندي
فبالعكس، قطاع السِّياحة، أنت سألتني على المدى الطَّويل
في بعضها على عشر سنوات، في بعضها على...
الآن احنا نأخذ من البنوك احنا عشر سنوات
فمن الطَّبيعي أنك تأخذ إثنا عشر أو ثلاثة عشر سنة، مع فتره سماح
وبعدين تنزل التسهيلات
ولا اللي بيصير أن بالنِّهاية بيصير أنك أنت إجباري يعني غصبًا عنَّك
لو ما جاءت هذه القروض، أيش تتخيل بيصير في السوق؟
أنا أتوقع أنه خلال كم سنة الجاية شيء طبيعي وذكرت وكُتبت
راح يكون نوع من الإقفالات
أنتُم كم فرع ممكن تقفلون؟
احنا ممكن نقفل...
من الـ30 هذه، كم بيكون راح جمكم بعد سنتين
لو الوضع زي ما هو ما تغير شيء؟
أنا أجزم لك أن في خمسة إلى ستَّة مطاعم راح تقفل
مطاعم ولا فروع؟
هي فروع بس اسم مطعم
ممكن اسم مطعم خلاص يطلع
فممكن خمسة إلى ستَّة
طبعًا
تقفلها تمامًا
اليوم هي قاعدة تدعم
قلت لك الشَّركة ‫ما توزِّع أرباح
وأنا أتوقع كل الشَّركات
‫أَنتُم على مستوى المجموعة كشركة المأكولات العصرية
صحيح
تربحون أم تخسرون؟
نخسر
نتائجكم المالية في 2022 خسارة؟
طبعًا 23 مليون
خسارة 23 مليون، السَّنة هذه كم؟
المتوقعة 31 مليون
31 مليون
عام 2021؟
18 مليون
فالخسارة قاعدة تزيد
طبعًا، أنت تتكلم خسائر مستمرة، فالواقع غير
فهذا أول طلب مطلوب أن الصندوق السِّياحي يدخل، ويعطيكم قروض
أيًّا كان الصندوق السِّياحي أو أن يفكر فيها، كيف ندعم...؟
أيش في طلب ثاني ممكن يفرق معاك الآن؟
سوى الصندوق السياحي دعم
دعم الطلبة السعوديين اللي راحوا ودرسوا بالخارج
هو جالس يدعم
عندك المقابل المالي
المقابل مالي
في أيام الكورونا، القطاع الصناعي أخذ إعفاء من المقابل المالي
هل تقدر تشتغل من غير عمالة؟ ما تقدر
بس عفوًا، القطاع الصناعي ما أخذوا في وقت كورونا
القطاع الصناعي أخذه في 2019
2019، بالضبط قبل كورونا
حزمة دعم لخمس سنوات، وكان فيها مبرر
لأن ترى كل القطاع الخاص يبغى يشيل هذا المقابل
ما أحد قدر إلا الصناعي
لأنهم قالوا له احنا ندخل في منافسة غير عادلة مع منتجات برَّة السعوديَّة
فأنا قاعد أنافس مصانع في الصين
صحيح
ماعندهم المقابل المالي
بينما بقيَّة القطاعات ما عندها هذا النُوع من الإغراق اللي من برة
أنت ما أحد ينافسك في السعوديَّة إلا مطاعم سعودية زيَّك
وعليها المقابل المالي
صح
فموضوع المقابل المالي
وكلها متأثرة
وبالتالي المقابل المالي ما أظن أن وزارة المالية شالته عن أحد
ليش بتتوقع راح يشيلونه عنكم؟
يخفف التكلفة عشان تكون أنت...
أنت عشان تنافس عالميًّا قلنا أنه في قطاع في له مُحدِّدات
إذا أنت تكلفة العمالة عندك تمثل 35 إلى 40%
خلال أنه برَّة في مجالك هذا في المطاعم الفاخرة
هي تمثل من 26% إلى 28%
معناته التركيبه عندك فيها خلل
إي
هذا واحد، فأنت كيف تنزل إلى الطَّبيعي
بحيث تكون جَدوَاك الاقتصادية مقنعة ومقبولة، هذا واحد
لازم تسويه، تنزل
عندك هذا المقابل المالي
بعدين عندك موضوع أنك أنت كشركة
أنت لازم تشوف موضوع السَّكن وفي تقسيم للسكن
وفي أشياء هذه...، هذه رفعت التَّكاليف
قلت لك كنا ثمانية ريال السرير، الآن ثلاثة وعشرين ريال
على طاري الخدمات هذه، أنتم كيف علاقتكم مع إجادة؟
الحمد لله كويسة
كم تدفع مخالفات سنويًّا كمجموعة؟
والله في
وصلتوا المليون ولا أكثر؟
لا، أقل الحمد لله
أقل من مليون، كم مخالفاتكم؟
والله ما يحضرني الرَّقم،
لكن فيه مخالفات لكن ما هي...
هل تغيرت الشَّركة مؤخرًا، ولا ما زال نفس التَّحدي؟
مؤخرًا خفت الزيارات
بس أعطيك مثال بسيط
أنت مثلًا على الشارع العام لو حطيت القمع الأحمر
قدام الموقف اللي قدام باب المطعم
اللي هو القمع الأحمر
القمع الأحمر، على طول جاءت وصورت هذه مخالفة
أنا ما حجزته للمطعم
ولا حجزته عشان زبائن معينة أو مهمة
بس في النِّهاية السيارات اللي توقف قدام المطعم هي واجهة
والله أحيانًا ولا نقصًا في أحد
عامل كشغل حر، معاه سيارة بسيطة جدًّا
وقف على الشارع وراح مثلًا، وقف قدام المطعم
وراح مثلًا يلاقي اجتماع أو شغل ولا أي شيء
زي ما أقول لك، عامل حر
أنت برَّة كل المطاعم هذه تلاقيه عادي
أنه شيء طبيعي يحاول ينظف المنظر الخارجي
وما قدام الخارجي لأن هذا يستقطب
ولو حطيت شيء غير مناسب كمان ينفر
بس هذه مواقف بلدية وعامَّة ما هي لكم
ما هي لنا
يقدر أي أحد يوقف فيها
هي ما هي لنا، بس هي قدام مين؟
أنا أعطيك مثال، أنا ماني قاعد أدخل، وأنا معاك هي مواقف عامة
بس المخالفات تجي على أقل شيء
أحيانًا مو أقل شيء، أحيانًا تجيبوا اللحم خربان
خلاص
طلعت
هذه زمان، هذه سالفة...
طلعت عليكم سالفة اللَّحم الخربان أنتم؟
اللَّحم الفاسد
أيش قصة اللَّحم الفاسد؟
هذا، طال عمرك، أتوقع أنك تعرفها
بس القصة هذه كانت للَّحم المُقدد أو اللَّحم
المُعتَّق
إي
ففي زيارة كانت سابقة وقديمة، والحمد لله، أنَّها تغيرت الأمور
ولا عاد هذه... بس سالفة مُضحكة
في زيارة في مفتشين كان المطعم ممتلئ
ما شاء الله تبارك الله، كان مساء يوم ثلاثاء أو أربعاء، ناسي
الساعة تسعة ونص أو عشرة
وجاؤوا الأخوة أخواننا المفتشين من «إجادة» ثلاثة ودخلوا المطعم
أنا لحقت عليهم، فقالوا لي أن أنتُم عندكم يوجد لحم فاسد
قلت: وين اللحم؟
قالوا:ض أتلفناه
كم كيلو؟ ثمانين كيلو
ثمانين؟
ثمانين كيلو
أتلفناه في، الله يعزِك، الحاوية حَقَت المُخلفات
فقلت: طيب، ليش أتلفتوه؟
قالوا أن طريقة تخزينه
قلت: هذا لحم مقدد
قال: لا ما في شيء اسمه لحم مقدد، وإلى آخره
طيب أنت أتلفت الثمانين كيلو؟
قال إي، لأن اللي برَّة هو جزء من اللَّحم الباقي
فاحنا أخذنا اللي أنت مخزنه اللي جالس تسوِّي له تجفيف
واللي هو تابع له اللي من نفس النوع
اللي في الثَّلاجة أخذناهم كلهم أتلفناهم
إلا تسكر المطعم، ما تسكر المطعم
طيب، أستنى النَّاس تُخرج، أستنى مادري أيش
المهم أصرُّوا على إقفال المطعم
والزَّباين موجودين
إي، طبعًا أقتنعتهم أني قلت عيب
تقفل المطعم والنَّاس موجودين، خلوا النَّاس تطلع
بعدما تطلع النَّاس، أنت أيش مصلحتك؟
بعدما تطلع النَّاس، نسكر المطعم
فعلًا المهم تم الاتفاق على تسكير المطعم
بس هذا كلام زمان، تغيرت الأنظمة من بعدها
فقالوا بكرة الصَّباح تراجع
رحت أنا، راجعت قلت وين نتيجة المختبر؟
اللَّحم فاسد يروح للمختبر
قال: لا احنا أتلفناها، ما فيه نتيجة مختبر
لا كذا ما يصير
أولًا، لازم فيه عمليَّة وخطوات
إذا في لحم فاسد تروح للمختبر
المختبر يطبعلك عينة، يقول لك أن اللَّحم فاسد حسب النتائج
أمَّا أنت كونك يعني أعطيت قرارك في لحظتها، وأتلفته بالكامل
ومن غير ما تأخد عيِّنة إلى المختبر، صعب شوي
فهذا اللي صار
وكم تقفل المطعم؟
إلى ثاني يوم الساعة ثلاثة العصر، تم افتتاحه
بس علَّقوا عليه ستيكر أو شيء زي كذا؟
علَّقوا عليه ملصق
أن فيه لحم فاسد
لا، إغلاق المطعم
إغلاق المطعم
إي يحطُوه هم إغلاق، ما يحطوا السَّبب على الملصق
يحطُّوا بس إغلاق المطعم
بس في تويتر انتشر
بس انتشر في تويتر، وصار فيه تأثير سَلبي
جلس المطعم ثلاثة أسابيع إلى أن يرجع إلى طبيعته
لدرجة بعض الموظفين الأجانب كانوا يظنوا أن هذه نهاية «نزومي»
أن خلاص بنسكر المطعم، وأنهم راح يخسروا وظائفهم، تخيل
كنت أجتمع معهم، ونقول لهم: يا جماعة ما راح تخسر وظيفتك
والمطعم راح يرجع، وراح ترجع الأمور
قال لا، خلاص
أيش اللي اختلف في تجربة...
ثاني يوم ما في أحد في المطعم
فُتح باب المطعم، ما في أحد
ما أحد راضي يدخل المطعم
هذا كان موقف سابق، أيش اللي اختلف الآن؟
لأن أكثر من مسؤول حكومي
يؤكدون أن طريقة التفتيش والرقابة صارت فيها تدرَّج وإمهال وتنبيه أولًا
تنبيه أولًا، وما في عاد في الارتجالية هذه
أن ما يجرأ المفتش أن يأخذ ويرمي من غير ما يعطي دليل واضح
دليل مدعم إما باختبار أو تحاليل، وفيه نتيجة
فالارتجالية هذه في القرار ما هي موجودة
ثاني شيء، أول زمان كان يجي البلاغ ممكن يسموه بلاغ كيدي
يجيك بلاغ، يقول لك: فيه أحد بلَّغ
تخيل أنا ممكن أبلَّغ على واحد من المنافسين بلاغ كيدي
ويروح يفتشوا عليه
فنبهنا قلنا: يا جماعة ما ينفع
ترى فيه بعض، للأسف أنه هذه لما تجيكم بلاغات كيدية
ما يجب أنك تتخذ على طول قرارك، وتقوم بالتفتيش، وهو بلاغ كيدي
فما عاد صار في هذا الشيء موجود، وهذه تحسنت كثير
فصارت الآن الزَّيارة...
هل الأخطاء واضحة وصرتوا أَنتُم تعرفون...؟
لأنه يرسل لك الأخطاء بالصور
ويرسل لك الصُّورة، يقول لك مثلًا هذا الشيء كان مكشوف
هذا الشيء ما كان نظيف أو الثلاجة درجة...
راح ينبهك أوَّل قبلَما...؟
في صار تنبيه، وفي صار مُخالفات
حسنًا، وهذا المطلوب
وهذا المطلوب
إذا أنت مخالف لازم تدفع
الآن تجيك بالصُّور، وتجيك على النِّظام
تُرفع على النِّظام، كل شيء عن طريق النِّظام
وفيه كان فيه أسئلة أبو عبد الله على موضوع التَّمويل
أَنتُم من القلَّة اللي عندكم وصول لتمويل البنوك
البنوك ما تقرض مطاعم، أيش السِّر؟
شلون قاعدين تأخدون فلوس من البنوك؟
يا سلام، أنا قبلَما أدخل البنوك قضيت
أكثر من خمسة عشر سنة في البنوك
قبلَما تدخل قطاع المطاعم قصدك؟
قبلَما أدخل قطاع المطاعم عفوًا
خمسة عشر سنة في البنوك؟
أي أو أكثر
بدأت طال عمرك من أيام ما كنت أدرس ماجستير في أمريكا
اشتغلت مع «ميري لينش» في 2001 و2002
لما رجعت التحقت في 2003 «بالبنك البريطاني»
كملت مسيرتي في «بالبنك البريطاني»
إدارة الشركات «كوربت المصرفية» وتمويل الشركات
مر علي وموَّلت، كان عندي 150 عميل
فاشتغلت في سنين طويلة إلى الـ 2010
انتقلت إلى الخدمات المصرفية الاستثمارية
مسكت «باركليز» السعوديَّة والبحرين
كنت مسؤول إدارة الثروة والاستثمار في «باركليز»
التحقت في «عودة كابيتال» كمدير تنفيذي
فالحمد لله، عندي خبرة كبيرة
ونفس الشي طبعًا الشُّركاء عندهم خبرة برضو في مجال المَصارف
وأخوي أسامة ما يزال المدير التَّنفيذي
للـ«جي.أي.بي كابيتال»
ففي خبرة في مجال المصارف كبيرة
فالحمد الله، كانت خبرتي في «الخدمات المصرفية للشركات»
كنت أناوش وأحارب مع البنوك وأقنع، وأسوي عُروض وأسوي...
ففعلًا صحيح
أبو عبد الله آسف إنِّي أقاطعك لكن...
من حديثك السَّابق كل عقاراتك مُستأجرة، وثلاثة أرباع مطاعمك تخسر
البنوك لا يمكن تقرض هذا النوع من النَّشاط، علِّمنا السِّر
ما عمره في يوم من أيام تأخر السداد نهائيًّا
المدفوعات وجدولة المدفوعات ماخذة وقتها
فقروضي في عشر سنوات، وفي 8 سنوات
شلون أقنعتهم؟
حسنًا
شارك هذه الخبرة مع المستثمرين الآخرين اللي عندهم اليوم مطاعم
وما عمرهم أخذوا قروض من البنوك
صحيح
أيش يحتاج البنك عشان يبدأ يقرض هذه الشَّركات؟
أولًا يحتاج يشوف أن أنت كشركة أوراقك مرتبة وقوائمك المالية واضحة
احنا عندنا
«إيرسون يونق» على سبيل المثال
عندنا واحد من الأربعة الكِبار
وطبَّقت الـ «أي.إف.إس 16» قبلَما يكون إلزامي
وقبلها «أي.إف.إس 9» طبقتهم قبل...
هذه معايير محاسبية؟
هذه معايير محاسبية نقلت عليها قبلَما تكون إجباريَّة
وخسرت وانحسبت علي الإيجارات بطريقة مختلفة
وبدأت الخسائر تطلع وطبقتها قبل، ليش، استبقت...
فهذه نُقطة
يشوفوا البنوك ويراجعوا، أنت عندك إجراءات سياسيَّة
عندك ترتيب في الشَّركة
عندك أنظمة شايفين جالسين نسوي نظام «إي.آر.بي»
ونظام «إي.آر.بي» مُتمكِّن
والتفاصيل والتقارير اللي تطلع من الشَّركة
بس أعطيك بشهادة البنوك
يقولون لي: فيصل، التقارير هذه ما شفناها إلَّا من شركات كبيرة جدًّا
ما قِد شفنا شَركة تعطينا تقارير مُفصَّلة بالطريقة اللي أنت تعطينا إيَّاها
وهذه، الحمد لله، طبعًا بس عشان أشكر زملائي
وأخواني وعائلة «إم أف سي» عائلة شركة المأكولات العصرَّية
اللي كل هذول يد وحدة قائمين عليها
أخذت 15 مليون من منشآت اللي هو الحد الأقصى
ورحت سويت عرض، أول مرَّة جاءني رفض
وقدمت إيميل رسمي، وطلبت أني أقابل منشآت
ورحت إجتمعت مع إحدى عشر واحد من إدارات مختلفة في منشآت لوحدي
عشان أعرض عليهم، ونتضارب ليش رفضتوني؟
إلى أن أقنعتهم، وطلعنا بالإقناع بأن الشَّركة تستحق الـ 15 مليون
البنوك أروح لهم أزورهم وأسوي عروض
يحضرها من رئيس المخاطر ورئيس الائتمان والمدير التَّنفيذي أحيانًا
ورئيس الشَّركة طبعًا والفريق كامل يشوفوا الشَّركة
ويجوا فريق معاي، زملائي كمان
عشان يشوفوا أن ما هي شخص واحد
هي ومجموعة أشخاص هي شركة وليس شخص...
وليست هي شركة عائليَّة أو أفراد
واليوم الحمد لله، عندنا تعرُّض مع البنوك في أكثر من 280 مليون
280 مليون تسهيلات بنكيَّة
تسهيلات، ولا في عليها غير الضَّمانات الشخصية
أنتم كشركاء موقعين ضمانات شخصية؟
كلنا طبعًا
سندات لأمر من الشَّركة الثلاثة؟
سندات لأمر ضمان وضمانات بالتَّضامن
بالتَّضامن
إي نعم
ضمانات بالتَّضامن، أنت عارف
إي ما فيها لعب
ما فيها لعب
أبدًا
حلقتك مع أبو خالد، وقلت له يعني
ما شاء الله، عليهم البنوك ما عليهم خوف حقهم دائمًا مضمون
أظن هذه بتكون تجربة مفيدة للأشخاص اللي...
فهذا اللي ساعدني كثير، هي تجربتي السَّابق
فيه أسئلة كثيرة أبو عبد الله على موضوع إصرار النَّجاح
أنت عندك تسعة أو إحدى عشر علامة تجارية
منها اثنين تربح، وسَبعة ما تربح
أكثر من اثنين تربح
أكثر من اثنين؟
إي، أكثر من اثنين
احنا قلنا «شكيتي» و«ميازو»
الحمد لله «شكيتي» الرِّياض و«شكيتي» جدة
«شكيتي» الخبر، توَّه بعد بس ما...
لا، أنا أتكلم كعلامات
إيجابي
يسمُّوه يهمني حتى لو «الأرباح قبل الفوائد والضرائب» إيجابي
أنا بالنَّسبة لي ربح
حسنًا
إيجابي بالنَّسبة لي ربح
أنا في شهر خليني أقول لك، كيف أخسر؟
البنوك كيف تموِّلني؟
صح في رمضان والصيف «الأرباح قبل الفوائد والضرائب» بالسالب
يجي من بعد الصيف يصير عندي إيجابي
على مدار السَّنة، تراكميًّا
هذه تضرب هذه، يصير في عندي «الأرباح قبل الفوائد والضرائب» سلبية
البنوك ليش تموِّلني؟ البنوك ما يهمها
أن ربحيَّتي تحت الرِّبح الصَّافي
أنا صافي الرِّبح حقِّي كسبان، وللا لا؟
أنا يهمني الكاش
«الأرباح قبل الفوائد والضرائب» إيجابيَّة في كثير من المطاعم
المطاعم هذه الكثيرة ما عليها تمويل
هي تسدد المطاعم اللي جالسه عليها التَّمويل
إي، ولكن المقصد أنه فيه...
عرفت اللي أقصده؟
صحيح
المقصد أن سواء أَنتُم ولَّا في السُوق في مطاعم تخسر، ومطاعم تربح
صح
أيش أسرار النَّجاح؟ هل احنا نتكلم على السعر؟
وللا الجو العام، وللا الخدمة وللا الطَّعم؟
أكيد كُلَّها مُهمة، فأرجوك لا تقل لي هذا الجواب
أيش الأهم من تجاربكم؟
أيش اللِّي رجَّع الزبون، هل هو السعر؟ وَللا الخدمة وللا الطَّعم وللا الجو؟
أيش أهم عُنصر؟
اللي الواحد لو عنده محدود، يعني في ناس ماعندهم 280 مليون
اللي عندكم، ما شاء الله تبارك الله
عنده 3 أو 4 مليون وللا أقل من ذلك
ما يقدر يجمع كل الخلطة هذه
لو يبي يركز على شيء واحد
في عالم المطاعم الرَّاقية، أيش أهم عنصر؟
جودة الأكل
جودة الأكل؟
رقم واحد، جودة الأكل
الخدمة الاحترافيَّة، بمعنى كلمة احترافيَّة
بعدين الاستمراريَّة
أنك تكون مُتعرِّج طالع نازل هذا اللي ما تبغاه
وهذا أسوأ شي لأي مطعم
صح
أنا شفت ناس كثير
للأسف يبدأ ممتاز بعدين فجأة أسأله عن الطَّاهي، يقول لي سافر
إذا سافر الطَّاهي، فاتح مطعم ليش؟
أهم عنصر هو الطَّاهي والمدير اللي عندك
أنت قررت أنك تفتح مطعم
العناصر الأساسيَّة الموجودة عندك في المطعم، هذه أساس
كأنك شلت عامود أساس
وأنت تبغى المطعم يكمل من غير أعمدة أساس، ما ينفع
في خسائر؟ طبعًا في خسائر، بس خسائرك أكثر
وأعلى بكثير، لو بدأت تشيل
لأن هناك يصير إفلاس، وليس خسائر
توصل مرحلة الإفلاس
وأنتُم شلون تحافظون على الطَّاهي عندكم؟
الحمد لله، الاستباق أو أن النَّاس اللي تطلع من عندنا
أقل من القليل
الفريق الموجود معانا نفس الفريق الموجود
من يوم «نزومي» أول مطعم فتحناه
شلُون؟
العلاقة مباشرة، والطَّاهي تقرير لي مباشرةً، كلهم
وعلاقتنا أكثر من صحوبية
نطلع مع بعض، ونتعشى مع بعض، ونسولف مع بعض
ونضحك مع بعض
لأن أنت استِضافة، والاستِضافة مرح
آسف ما احنا جيش
استِضافة، اسمها استِضافة
الطٌّهاه هذول فنَّانين
تِبغى تحَامل الطَّاهي
تقول له: أنت جيت اليوم الدوام ولا ما جيت اليوم الدوام؟
هذا غلط
ما تتعامل مع الفنان بالطَّريقة هذه
في طُرق للتَعامل معاهم
فالحمد لله، هذا الشيء يساعدنا على الحفاظ
ترى دائمًا الحفاظ ما هي أزوده
لا، نفسيًّا هو مرتاح
لأن أنت تحتاج أنه الفنَّان هذا يكون مبسوط
لأن في النهاية لو جاك وهو مغصوب، اعرف أن الأكل مضروب
صح
في أسئلة أبو عبدالله على موضوع
السؤال اللي هِنا لطيف
يتكلَّم على موضوع اللمسة أو المكوِّنات المحليَّة
نعم
تلاقي في مطعم في «وَكَف» مثلًا
هو جاب الكوكيز لكن حط فيه...
نكة القهوة
يعني حط فيه اللمسات
اللي هي الكوكيز الحساوي حط فيه سمسم
وحط فيه مكونات من... مع أنه هو كمنتج هو منتج
من خارج السًّعودية الكوكيز
صحيح
حط فيه اللَّمسات هذه فأعطاك طعم محلِّي
جاب كروسان الزَّعتر حَط معاه الدُّقة المَدينية أو...
صَح
فأعطاك نكهة محليَّة، وهكذا
في مُلاحظة على أن أغلب مطاعمكم تجي زَي ما هي من برَّة
ما تحطُّون اللمسة المحليَّة، أعطنا أمثلة
مثال «نزومي» اللي هو «ميازو» عندنا كيكة التمر
هذه كلِّن سواها ترى
بس أول من سواها
بالله أنتُم؟
«نزومي» من 2014
هذه صارت ثابتة
ثابتة
كيكة التمر هذه احنا سوِّيناها، ما عندهم كيكة التمر ما جاءت
ما قلت لك نصف قائمة الطعام
هذا مثال حلو، أيش في غيره؟
هذا مثال، وعندك طال عمرك
فيه في قائمة الطَّعام
دخَّلنا جبنة الرِيكوتَّا مع دبس التَّمر في «شكيتي»
حلَى موجود مع دبس التمر، هذا ما هو موجود
دخَّلنا في طلباتنا...، دخَّلنا مثلًا زَي ما تفضلت
الكروسان تجي عندنا في الطَّلبات سوينا في مقهى «إِرث»
في الفطور سوينا الفطاير
ما أقدر أقول إنها سعودية، ما هي سعودية بس الفطاير العربية
ومقهى «إِرث» جاي من كاليفورنيا
وعليها إقبال مرة كثير، فندخل كثير
سوِّينا سبانيش لاتيه بالقهوة السعوديَّة
نكهة قهوتنا، البُن
جميل، ففيه هذا التَّوجه
آسف, هي بالهيل أقصد، أنا أقول القهوة السعوديَّة
سبانيش لاتيه بالهيل
ففي كثير من الأشياء نحاول
بس ما نحب نغير في الهويَّة بشكل كبير
لأنه بعدين ممكن كمان فيه ناس تستنكر تغييرك
لازم يكون احترافي وبشكل مبين وغير مبين
كم مطعم عنده نجمة ميشلان في السعوديَّة؟
نجمة ميشلان؟
إي
الطَّاهي يعني اللي أعرفه «جيمخانا»
بس؟
نجم ميشلان الطَّاهي الموجود فيه
أعرف «مهراجا» الهندي الموجود في السِّلمانيَّة
الطَّاهي حقهم برضو ميشلان ستار الطَّاهي
أعرف مو «سكوتس»، «سباقو»
«وولف بانك» أظنَّه ميشلان ستار
أَنتُم ما أنتُم مهتمِّين بهذا الموضوع؟
لا، احنا نهتم بس ما صدفت أنه موجود
ولا تقليلًا من شأن الطَّاهي اللي عندنا
أنا بالنسبة لي أشوفهم أعلى من ميشلان ستار يعني أقدرهم
يستاهلون
في سؤال هنا ليش ما فيه مطعم فاخر سُعودي طلع للعالم؟
مطعم فاخر كأكلات سعوديَة؟
سواءً كأكلات سعودية أو مملوك من سعوديين
«ميازو» إن شاء الله
«ميازو» إن شاء الله، متى؟
الحمد لله، تجينا طلبات بس قلت لك القروض ما عندنا نقدر نأخذ أكثر
إي، مقفلين عليك الشركاء خلاص
تجينا طلبات لـ«ميازو»
تجينا طلبات لـ...
الحمد لله «ميازو» تجينا طلبات من برَّة
بشكل كثير، ما شاء الله تبارك الله
متى أول فرع برة السعوديَّة لـ«ميازو»؟ ووين راح يكون؟
أقدر أقول لك: احتمال في 2024
وين راح يكون؟ لسه ما نعرف جاءنا من دبي طلبات
جاءنا من أوربا طلبات
بس أقدر أقول لك أنه، إن شاء الله، ما تنتهي 2024
أو بداية 2025 يكون في فرع لـ«ميازو» خارج السُّعوديَّة
وهذا بس عشان نكشخ، وللا فعلًا مُجدي الموضوع؟
لا، مُجدي
مجدي؟
ومو بس كذا، عشان نثبت أن المطعم من السعودية
في الظَّاهر «إسهيل» فتح في لندن؟
«إسهيل» فتح في لندن
كيف تشوف تجربته؟
أنا ما أعرف، أنا ما رحت بس أسمع، إن شاء الله، أنه كويس
بس نثبت أن السعوديَّة قادرة أنها تصدر، مو بس تستورد
كم يجلس المطعم ويرجع رأس ماله؟
اليوم في وضع القِطاع الحالي
عشان نوعِّي النَّاس اللي قاعدة تدخل
اليوم؟
اليوم
أيش المتوسط لاسترداد رأس المال؟
واحد حَط مليون ريال في مطعم، متى يتوقع يستردَّها؟
لا بظروف اليوم، الوضع...
يمكن ما يستردَّها أبد.
نعم إي، أكون صادق معك
السُوق مرَّه متشبع
السوق فيه تشبع
فصاحب القرار لازم يكون عارف هو مُقدم على أيش؟
صاحب القرار هو لازم يكون عارف
لأن أنا أقول لك إيَّاها من الطَّبيعي إنك تشوف في مطاعم تسكر
فيه ناس كثيرة جالسة تنزف، يعني العمل يَنزف
من الطَّبيعي والقرار الصائب أنك توقف النَّزيف
في ناس قراراتها تكون متعلقة عاطفية
صح
أنا سولفت مع واحد صريح
قال لي: أنا ما راح أقفِّل لأنه ما بغى يُقال لي قفل مطعمك
بالضبط
عنده الغرور أو الذَّات متضخِّمة، اللي ما يبغى يقفل مطعمه
حتَّى هذا الغرور صدِّقني هي مؤقَّتة لأنه ما راح تكمِّل
في يوم من الأيام راح يكسر غروره
ويقفِّل مطعمه
فيقفِِّله من بدرِي أحسن له
هي جالس يعطي إبر مخدِّر، جالس يخدِّر العمل
وفي مطاعم كسبانة
ومن الطَّبيعي أن راح نشوف أن في فلترة وفيه من...
فبالتالي فيه ناس دخلوه وفيه عندهم الشَّغف والجَلَد
المطاعم تَشغيل مُدَّتها 365 يوم، أربع وعشرين ساعة
أنت تظن أنه النهار...
أنا في الليل بالنسبة لي ساعات الذَّروة
أن الزحمة في المطاعم في الليل
النَّاس ترتاح في الإجازة، أنا بالنسبة لي أيَّام الذَّروة في الإجازة
تلفوني فيه 600 مجموعة
ما بين مجموعة المُشغِّلين وما بين مجموعة للطُهاة
ما بين مجموعة الصِّيانة، وكل يوم تخرب عندك صِيانة
فجأة في وقت التَّشغيل، الفُرن خرب
فجأة في التَّشغيل، الكهرباء ....فجأة
النَّاس اللي جالسة في المطعم
هذه أربعة وعشرين ساعة شغَّالة
مقهى «إيرث» يشتغل أربعة وعشرين ساعة
المخبز والمخبوزات لمقهى «إيرث» تشتغل بعد الساعة اثنى عشر بالليل
عشان توصل من الساعة سبعة الصَّباح
وستَّة الصَّباح إلى الفروع
ليش الأستاذ فيصل بكل المطاعم حقته ما استهدف إلَّا طبقة واحدة؟
لا حرام
أَنتُم تستهدفون طبقة واحدة
أصحاب الدَّخل العالي، هو قصده كذا يمكن
تقصد من ناحية الدخل؟
ليش «شكيتي» و«كريزي بيتزا» طال عمرك؟
«كريزي بيتزا» أرخص من «شكيتي» كأسعار
وأعلى شوي من مقهى «إيرث»
ما زالت هذه الطَّبقة الفوق المتوسطة، صح؟
هي طبعًا حُريَّة خاصة
أنت مستثمر وتختار الشَّريحة ما أحد يقدر يناقشك فيه
بس أيش المنطق من استهداف هذه الشَّريحة؟
ليش ما دخلتوا في أشياء أكبر؟
أشياء أكبر، طبعًا «كيو سار» مثلًا
مطاعم سريعة
مطاعم الخدمة السريعة
إي
أنا ما أفهم فيها كثير، هذا واحد، صدقًا
حلو
ما أفهم فيها كثير
فبالتالي ما أتوقع أن كشركة، أنا على الصعيد الشخصي
كشركة ما عندها الرَّغبة أنهم يدخلوا فيها كثير
طريقتها جدًّا، وطريقة إدارتها مُختلفة
صحيح كلهم يشتغلوا في مجال الأكل وكل شيء
لكن إدارة مُختلفة
وما أقدر أفتي فيها لأني ما أفهم فيها كثير
في ناس يسألون كثير على كيف تُسوِّق للمطاعم الرَّاقية
لأن هذه ما تقدر تستهدف فيها
الطَّريقة التَّقليدية في التَّسويق المُباشر
صحيح
أيش أفضل طريقة للتسويق في هذا النوع من المطاعم؟
التَّسويق الشَّفهي يلعب دور مرَّة كبير
الكلمة المُتداولة بين النَّاس
النَّاس تثق فيها مرَّة كثير
ومواقع التَّواصل الإجتماعي بجميع قنواتها
لمَّا النَّاس تِجي، بطبيعة الحَال...
تدفعون لمؤثرين أَنتُم؟
لا
أبدًا؟
لا، نستضيف لمَّا نفتح مطعم جديد
المؤثرين إذا كانو هُم من قائمة مُرتادي مطاعمنا
فهو بالطَّبيعي هو جاي عشانه...
احنا ما نسميه «في.آي.بي» نسميه ولاء للمطعم
الشيء الطَّبيعي أنك تأخذ، نطلع...
أنا أعطيك مثال، نَّاس كثير تيجي
نبغى نفتح مطعم جديد
احنا عندنا قائمتنا 550 ألف، ما أقدر أعزم 550 ألف
بس أقول نطلع أعلى 200 شخص زيارات
وزي ما تسوي البنوك وزي ما تسوي أي مكان وأي علامة تجارية في العالم
هم أكثر من 200 شخص
الـ 200 شخص يجي من ضمنهم، ما شاء الله، نَّاس مؤثرة
ناس عندها مواقع عامَّة، ونَّاس لها متابعين ومعروفين
هذول ندعيهم، وهو من ضمن القائمة
واحد يقول في جَشع عالي في أسعار المشروبات
في المطاعم اللي في السعوديَّة
فالماء يكون أعلى بكثير من أي ماء حول العالم
أنتُم تبالغون في أسعار المشروبات، هي أعلى هَامِش عندكم صح؟
المشروبات هي اللي تسوِّيلنا هَامِش
باقي الأكل، بعض الأكل نبيعه بأقل هَامِش، بتكلفة منخفضة
بتكلفة منخفضة، أقل من تكلفته؟
أقل من تكلفته
وتعوض في المشروبات والحلى؟
وأعوض في المشروبات والحلى، بالضبط
هي الأعلى
لأنَّه ما فيها لا لحوم ولا أسماك ولا...
الطَّبق الرَّئيسي عادةً ما فيه ربح عالي صح؟
اللُّحوم ما فيها ربح
الربح في المُقبلات والمشروبات
أنا منزِّل أسعار مطعم «بييف بار»
تدري أن الأطباق الرَّئيسيَّة كلها بتكلفة منخفضة؟
فيه طال عمرك تساؤل على ...
مجموعة واحدة وإدارة عليا وحدة ومع ذلك فيه تفاوت في الخدمة
هذا مثلًا يضرب مثال يقول: «بليونير» تعاملهم معي ما كان كويس
لكن أروح «بييف بار» أو «سانيور ساسي» ألاقي خدمة ممتازة
طيب، إذا هو نفس الإدارة ونفس المالك
ليش يصير في هذا التَّفاوت في مستوى الخدمة؟
طبعًا هذه ملاحظة كويسة
بس أحيانًا تصدف هو راح في أي يوم
هو ذكر مثال جدًّا حلو
«بليونير» و«بييف بار»
«بليونير» و«بييف بار» ماسكهم لشخص واحد
عجيب
فهذا من ناحية إدارة
في واحد ماسك «بليونير» وماسك «بييف بار»
فكيف هذا كويس وهذا مو كويس؟
بالضَّبط، فهو صدفت ما تدري أحيانًا موقف
لكن احنا نحرص، الملاحظة كويِّسة، احنا نحرص دائمًا
ولهذا أقول لك ليش التَّشغيل ما هو سهل
في النِّهاية ما هو تشغيل آلي
وأحرص أنا بشكل يومي أني أمر
ما أقدر أمر كلها طبعًا، بس أسوِّي جدول، متى أروح أتعشى؟
وبالتالي نادرًا ما أطلع أروح أتعشَّى في مطاعم غير مطاعم الشَّركة
لأنَّه أنا في روحتي أضرب عصفورين بحجر
أستمتع بالأكل وأراقب الخدمة وأراقب الجودة
وعيني تجلس على الملاحظات
إذا كان معي أحد يقول لي يا أخي ملّينا من جلستنا معاك
لأن عيونك ما هي مَعانا
أكون لا شعوريًّا طبعًا أني أجلس أراقب الباب، وأراقب الخدمة
في واحد يسأل يقول يا أخي دائمًا الحجز يطلع لي فُل
أروح لمطعم ألقاه فاضي
وين، حدد مطعم يعني؟
لا، يتكلم بشكل عام
تعانون من هذا الموضوع؟
احنا تقريبًا نقبل كل الحجوزات، نادرًا ما نقول فل
إلا في مطاعم مُعيَّنة، ما أخفيك
عندنا في مدينة الرِّياض نتكلم
«سان كارلوا شكيتي»إذا كلم قبلها بوقت بسيط أكيد بيكون فل
وهو فل فعلًا
«ميازو» راح يكون فل و«سانيور ساسي» راح يكون فل
أكون صادق الثلاثة هذول، إذا كلم في نفس اليوم يكون فل
وهل تعانون من... كم نسبة الالتزام بالحجز؟
لأنه فيه كثير من أخوياي يحجز خمسة مطاعم
إي يحجز خمسة مطاعم
عشان متى ما بغى
احنا وقَّفناها، تخيل يبَيِّن إذا حجز في واحد من مطاعمنا
نقول له ترى عندك حجز ثاني
طبعًا، وقفناها لأنه كان يصير هذا الشيء
لأن عندنا مركز اتصال موحَّد لجميع المطاعم
فبالتالي يبَيِّن عندنا
راح بس اللي حاجز في «سانيور ساسي» و«إل.بي.أم» ما تقدروا تعرفوه
ما راح تقدر تعرف
فكم نسبة الالتزام بالحجوزات؟
بدون عرض عندنا تقريبًا يرتفع إلى 35% بشكل إجمالي وبشكل عام
يزيد أحيانًا وينقص أحيانًا
%35 من اللي يحجزون ما يحضرون؟
إي
كمتوسِّط
نعم، هذه عندنا موجودة دائمًا
أبو عبد الله فيه سؤال على موضوع الشَّارع اللي فيه نفس المطاعم
شارع كله شاورما، شارع كله برقر
في حالتكم أَنتُم بشارع كله مطاعم راقية
هل هذا يأكلون من بعض وينافسون بعض، ولا يسوِّقون لبعض؟
هم ما يأكلون، يمكن يسوقون لبعض
هي وجهة، أنت تخلق وجهة وتخلق منطقة جاذبة، ولا يكون مطعم جاذب
منطقة جاذبة
حسنًا
فهي تعتبر ميزة؟
ميزة
فاللي راح يفتح فرع يدور مطاعم تشبهها، ويروح يفتح جنبهم؟
بالضَّبط، لأن أنت جايتك الوجهة
يمكن في زيارات غير مخططة
عندنا شي اسمه زيارات غير مخططة
هو يجي من غير حجز
يمكن جاء «ميازو» ما لقى حجز
يقوم يروح على «سانيور ساسي» جنبه
أمَّا تخيَّل أن ما في شيء جنب «ميازو»
يضطر يضرب مشوار
ما شاء الله تبارك الله، الآن في الزَّحمة
نفس الشيء «فيا رياض»
أنا ممكن أدفع وأدخل «فيا رياض»
وجوَّا أثناء ما أنا أتمشَّى نقرر المطعم المُتاح أدخله
ممكن ماني مقرر من البيت، ويمكن ما كنت جيعان
لمَّا تقررت ولا...، عرَفت
نفس الشيء «البجيري»
ممكن أبغى أروح أتمشى
جلَست أتمشَّي ساعة أو ساعتين أتمشى
جلَست في قهوة، وبعدين قررت أتعشى، في لحظتها أقرر
كم الدخل اليومي لـ«ميازو»؟
أنا أقدر أجاوب بطريقة دُبلوماسيَّة
أعَطنَا دخل المجموعة طيب
اليومي؟
إي
يتراوح، تتكلم أنت في أيام العز؟ كان يسوي في اليوم مليونين
في اليوم، ما شاء الله تبارك الله، مليونين
وأَيام التَّقشف؟
أَيام المنافسة القويَّة تنزل إلى 1.3 أو 1.2
1.2 في اليوم؟
المتوسِّط وتطلع في الإجازات تزيد
بس المتوسط عندنا 1.2
السجل حَقَّكم؟
السجل حَقَّنا 2.1 أو 2.2
2.2 في يوم واحد، هذا كان السِجل، ما شاء الله تبارك الله
فيه سؤال على... أعتبره سؤال قبل الختام
أفتح في مبنى مُستقل ولا ضمن مجمع؟
اليوم في المجمعات التِّجارية العقاريَّة
مثلًا: «ذا زون» و«ليسن فالي» و«كافت» و«فيا رياض»
وللا أفتح لحالي؟
هذه لها إيجابيَّات وسلبيَّات
إذا فتحت لحالك فاللي راح يجيك يجيك، يجيك متعَنِّي
إذا فتحت في تجمُّع، يجيك اللي جاي بالصُّدفة
تستفيد من اللي جاي بالصُّدفة
فلها إيجابيَّات وسلبيَّات
أنت توصيتك؟
تجربتنا في المُستقل كانت مميزة
وتجربتنا من ضمن مجمع عندنا مقهى «إيرث»في كافت
عندنا في عود سكوير، فالتَّجربتين مميزتين
إذا كان نوع المطبخ حقك، ما في أحد يجيه بالصُّدفة، خليك مُستقل
إذا كان نوع المطبخ حقك، اللي هو مطبخ أكثر عُموميَّة
يخدم النَّاس كلَّها، علامة للناس، خليك في مكان عام
لأن راح تستفيد من وقع الأقدام الموجود
سؤال آخر أبو عبدالله
اليوم في ناس على عدة مراحل
في مرحلة اللي فكر يسوِّي مطعم
في مرحلة اللي بدأ يسوي المطعم حقه بس ما قفَّل
أو ما أنهى مرحلة التنفيذ، ودخل في التَّشغيل
وفي اللي داخل في التَّشغيل، وقاعد يأكل خسائر
هذول الثلاثة نبغى نختم الحلقة
بتوصية منك كشخص خبير موجود في القطاع
لكل واحد من هذول الثلاثة، أيش تُقول له؟
اللي قاعد يفكر اليوم بس يأخذ في دراسات الجدوى
وفي الحسبان أن في زيادة في المعروض
اللي هو داخل غير رسمي، وداخل المجال الراقي
يسوي دراسته مضبوطة
ويشوف المطبخ، هل هذا متشبع؟
إيطالي أو ياباني أو صيني أو هندي، يدوِّر من النَّاحية هذه
وهل المنتج اللي راح يقدمه، هل راح يكون جدًّا مميز؟
لأن الآن يجب أن يكون جدًّا مميز عشان يقدر ينافس
وعنده الشَّغف، ولا ما عنده الشَّغف؟
إذا كانت هي فقط مبلغ عنده، حرام يضيع
لأن المطاعم مو هي أعلى عائد استثمار أو أفضل حتى في أفضل أيامها
ترى فيه أدوات استثمارية أخرى تعطيه عائد أعلى
فهي مربوطة بشغف، فهذه نصيحة
هذه نصيحتها للي ما بعد بدأ
للي ما بعد بدأ لأنه في مرحلة التَّفكير
حلو
اللي بدأ وفي نص المشوار، وما بعد فتح
عنده القدرة قبلَما يفتح يشوف حجم المطعم
ويشوف عدد الكراسي
نصيحة أنه ما يتعدى 120 كرسي
ما يتعدى 120 كرسي
لأن تخدمه في الأيام
لأنه كلَّما زاد عدد كراسي كلَّما زاد عدد الموظفين
كلَّما زاد حجم المطبخ، كلَّما زاد عدد أشياء مرَّة كثير
فبالتالي كلفة التَّشغيل فيها تطلع عالية كثير
فهناك في تخفيف للخطر، لمَّا يخليه على 120
هذه جزئيَّة مهمة
وإذا نوى يفتح يفكر في موضوع الدَّيمومة
لا يفتح، ويقول راح أجرب
كلمة راح أجرب راح يترتب عليها خسائر كثيرة
أجل أيش المفروض يسوِّي؟
إذا قرر أن يفتح، يفتح صح، ويعطي مهلة فترة زمنية صح
كم من الفترة الزَّمنيَّة؟
النَّاس يقولون شهر العسل
ثلاثة أو ستة شهور هذه دائمًا النَّاس أمورهم حلوة ثم...
هذا غلط
لازم يقول أنا لازم أكون مُستمر
وعلى ما أنا عليه أقل شي سنتين
سنتين؟
إي، أقل شيء سنتين
يحط في حسابات المشروع سنتين قاعد يخسر
لكن عنده التَّمويل لتغطية المصروفات
إي، عنده الرَّواتب مَرصد الرَّواتب، وكل شيء هذه أشياء...
فهذا نصيحة للي في النص
إي والله
نصيحة للي متدبس وخسران الحين
اللي متدبس وخسران عنده قرارين
أول شيء يشيل العاطفة في اتخاذ القرار، لأن هذا غلط
يفكر في اتخاذ القرار بناءً على قدرته، وقدرة الشَّركة الماليَّة
هل عنده خطَّة أنه يسوي تحول؟
إما أنه يسكر المطعم، ويفتح مطبخ ثاني
كان فاتح صيني يسكر، يمكن ما فيه جدوى للصيني، يفتح هندي
هذا واحد من الخيارات
أو يسكر المطعم نهائيًّا إذا هو ما راح يقدر يعيد افتتاحه بشكل مميز
فيسكر نهائيًّا
بس أنه يكمل في الخسائر
أنا كأني اقولك كمِّل وضيع فلوسك، حرام ضاعت
لا تندم على اللي راح، بس تندم على القرار أنك تستمر في الشيء هذا
أنا نسيت سؤال برضو كان مهم ونصيحة مهمَّة
في منظومة القطاع نفسها، النَّاس كلها تفكر تسوِّي مطعم
لكن في عشرات الشَّركات اللي تخدم هذا المطعم
فأَنتُم من واقع حجمكم ومطاعمكم
أيش الخدمات المساندة اللي تحس اليوم أنَّها مُجدية وفيها فلوس
وفي احتياج في السٌّوق
فتقول للناس فَكِّروا في هذه الخدمة
أو هذا القطاع المساند للمطاعم
لأن احنا قاعدين نعاني من عدم توفر أو من سوء في الجودة
أو أنه ما في كفاية في السُّوق
أيش القطاعات المساندة اللي لسه فيها فرص؟
عشان النَّاس ما تفكِّر مطاعم
ممكن يفكرون في القطاع بشكل عام
القطاع بشكل عام
لو جيت تسألني أنا اليوم أشوف الموردين
أقول لك لا برضو الموردين في الأكل
فيه عندهم مخاطرة عالية جدًّا
لو ما حصَّلوا فلوسهم لأنهم بالتسديد الآجل
ثلاثين أو ستين يوم
وكثير من المطاعم الآن جالسة تتأخر في السَّداد على الموردين
الموردين مو قطاع تنصح فيه
إي، هذه نقطة
النُّقطة الثَّانية إذا جينا نتكلم عن البناء، مواد ما لها حدود
ولا تقدر تحددها لأنه كل ديكور يختلف، وكل الإحتياجات مختلفة
شركات تقديم خدمات العمالة
تأجير خدمات عمالة، مليانة ومنتشرة
هذه من الأشياء مثل «مهارة» وغيرها
فما شاء الله تبارك الله، الشركات منتشرة
إذا جيت تتكلم عن الشركات المساندة اللي تقدم سكن
ما تعرف، ممكن بكرة يقول لك خلاص ما في تقسيم
فأنت تكون استثمرت، وغير كذا التَّنوع كثير
أنت بتنافس أيش؟
يمكن قد تكون تقنية المعلومات
تقنية المعلومات
أنظمة
أيش أكثر نظام اليوم أنت تحتاجه، وما أنت لاقيه في السوق؟
أبغى نظام يربط الاتصال
من وقت ما يجيني اتصال الحجز إلى أني أخذ الحجز وأدخله
إلى وصوله لنقطة البيع بنقطة البيع
الزبون يجي طالع
مربوط بالمخزن اللي عندك
إلى أنه مربوط بالماليَّة مباشرة عندك
وكل هذا مربوط مع الموارد البشريَّة
مع الدخول والطُّلوع والتَّبصيم
وعدد الساعات والسَّاعات الإضافيَّة
وحسبة السَّاعات الإضافيَّة، والعُطل
تبغى تخطيط موارد المشاريع كامل لقطاع المطاعم؟
تخطيط موارد المشاريع كامل من الألف إلى الياء
هذه فرصة لروَّاد الأعمال، اللي عنده هذا الحل يكلم أبو عبد الله
الله يبارك فيك، تسلم أبو عبد الله
شكرًا على قبول الدَّعوة، شرَّفتنا ونوِّرتنا
يا طويل العمر
بالتوفيق في 2026
إن شاء الله
تفرحون في السوق، وتكونوا ربحانين
إن شاء الله، بإذن الله
الله يفتح عليك
شكرًا لك
أبو عبدالرحمن، شكرًا الله يسلمك
شكرًا لكم
شكرًا لفهد القصِّير في إعداد وإنتاج هذه الحلقة
في التحرير: أنس الخليل
فؤاد الهتلان في الإخراج الإبداعي
عبد الرحمن خالد في إدارة التصوير
في الإضاءة: إسماعيل شوقي
في تسجيل الصوت: عبد الرزاق المزِّي
وفي الهندسة الصوتية: عبد العزيز المزِّي
وفي إدارة الإنتاج: عبد المجيد عمر
وفي الإشراف على الإنتاج: رزان دهيثم
هذا بودكاست سُقراط، أحد منتجات شركة ثمانية للنشر والتَّوزيع